merci beaucoup monessieur donc d'être
présent ce matin il est toujours
précieux d'avoir le point de vue des
experts qui nous permettent de resituer
nos travaux dans un contexte économique
décrypté et plus accessible monsieur
bouou vous êtes auteur spécialisé sur le
sujet économique directeur de cabinet de
conseil
Asteres petite anecdote vous concernant
la première fois que je vous ai
rencontré je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez c'était en haute zone vous êtes
sur mon département vous êtes venu vous
avez répondu une invitation de mon ami
Jean-Luc KIV président de la Chambre de
commerce industrie et ce qui m'en reste
c'est une citation vous avez fait que
j'utilise de temps en temps de
schumpetter le neuf ne n'est pas de
l'ancien il n'est à côté se développe et
finit par le tuer je m'en sers de temps
en temps même en
poliique monsieur desertine vous êtes
professeur à l'Institut d'Administration
des Entreprises de l'Université Paris 1
Panthéon Sorbonne directeur de
l'Institut de haute finances à Paris et
président de l'association Comité 21 la
délégation aux entreprises est sur le
point de de présenter ses conclusions
sur deux missions consacrées à la
directive CSRD et à la pénurie du
foncier économique nous venons tout
juste de nommer les rapporteurs des deux
missions à venir sur les thèmes
entreprises et climat et le financement
de l'entreprise de demain tous ces
sujets mettent en évidence les divers
défis auxquels sont confrontés les
entreprises notre rôle est d'analyser
les difficultés rencontré en particulier
par les TPE PME ETI afin de formuler des
propositions utiles et
efficace votre point de vue sur ces
thématiques et sur beaucoup d'autres
seront très utiles à notre délégation
pour formuler des recommandations
pertinentes vous pourrez notamment nous
expliquer les interactions entre ces
différents sujets par exemple le lien
entre la RSE et financement je ne vais
pas vous adresser de questions précis à
ce stade car les rapporteurs des
différentes missions seront invités à
vous interroger néanmoins je
souhaiterais recueillir votre point de
vue sur une difficulté récurrente qui
est celle du chiffrage des phénomènes et
enjeux
il suffit de lire l'étude d'impact d'un
projet de loi ayant des conséquences sur
les entreprises pour comprendre que nous
manquons de culture économique et
d'outils pour appréhender et mesurer
correctement les effets d'une mesure
alors est-ce est-on aujourd'hui en
mesure de mieux faire et comment
développer une culture de l'étude
d'impact plus efficace qui puisse être
utile notamment au travail du
législateur je vais vous laisser la
parole pour un propos introductif
d'environ 12 minutes chacun puis je
demanderai à mes collègues rapporteurs
de poser leurs questions et à mes autres
collègues nous devrons terminer cette
rencontre à 9h40 je crois que vous avez
un impératif je rappelle que ce débat
est capté et retransmis en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat monsieur bouou je
vous propose de commencer vous avez 12
minutes merci merci monsieur le
Président bonjour à toutes et tous alors
je vais répondre à à vos questions mais
je saisis la Ball au bon sur la question
des études d'impact et aussi de de
l'évaluation ation parce que c'est dans
l'actualité et je voudrais vous faire
part d'une directive très importante qui
n'a pas fait l'objet d'une étude
d'impact ou plus exactement qui a fait
l'objet d'une étude d'impact après avoir
été adopté c'est la directive européenne
de la ferme à la fourchette dont on
parle beaucoup en ce moment dont les
études d'impact ont montré qu'elle
aboutissait à une diminution de la
production agricole en Europe et en
particulier à une diminution de la
production d'élevage et en effet on ne
peut que regretter que ce type de
travaux n''estit pas été fait je dirais
en en amont et plus
globalement notamment en France il est
clair que en matière de politique
publique il existe un déficit en matière
d'étude d'impact mais peut-être plus
encore en matière d'évaluation c'est que
le sentiment que l'on a dans le domaine
quand on regarde les politiques
publiques de l'extérieur c'est que au
fond une fois qu'elles sont adopté on
considère que le problème qu'elles
étaient censé régler est réglé et on
oublie un peu les choses chose et je
pense que c'est une mauvaise façon de de
faire et qui a beaucoup à voir avec un
autre sujet du moment alors qu'il a pour
le coup sera sans doute au cœur de notre
discussion ce matin notamment quand on
va parler de de la question de la
transition écologique qui est au fond la
prolifération des normes c'estàdire qu'à
partir du moment où on ne sait pas bien
évaluer à postériori
l'impact d'une loi ou d'un règlement peu
importe on a beaucoup beaucoup moins
d'outils pour militer pour son retrait
et du coup on a un empilement une
prolifération de de normes qui finit par
avoir un coup sur sur l'économie alors
je reviens au au sujet que vous nous
avez demandé de traiter ce matin je vais
commencer par la question du du
foncier peut-être déjà un tout petit mot
de de cadrage
puisque le gouvernement le président et
le gouvernement ont mis en place une
stratégie de réindustrialisation
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
fait consensus dans notre pays on est à
peu près tous d'accord pour dire que
notre pays c'est très fortement
désindustrialisé et que à beaucoup
d'égards c'est un problème parce
que finalement le la recherche et
développement se fait beaucoup dans
l'industrie parce que ce sont
essentiellement les secteurs industriels
qui qui exportent parce que l'industrie
aussi présente l'avantage je dirais
socialement d'être assez réparti sur le
sur le territoire donc il y a un
consensus pour
dire que la la France doit se
réindustrialiser il y a quand même un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises depuis 6 ans et qui vont dans ce
sens-là notamment dans le domaine fiscal
mais pas que et quand on regarde un peu
là où on en est en terme de
résultat je dirais la meilleure formule
que j'ai trouvé c'est il y a peut-être
un début de quelque chose euh quand on
regarde les projets industriels bon vous
le voyez dans vos territoires mais ils
sont très nombreux sans doute même don
on jamais été aussi nombreux donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très positif
c'est parfaitement attesté he par tous
les classements sur l'attractivité de la
France avec quand même quelques nuances
bon déjà ce sont des projets ensuite ce
sont plutôt de petits projets et assez
souvent ce sont des projets de de de de
modernisation plus que des projets
d'extension et donc quand on regarde les
les chiffres pour voir vraiment là où on
en est en matière d'industrialisation et
ça va m'amener directement à la question
du foncier vous allez voir mais le
sentiment qu'on a c'est
que a il y a quelque chose qui qui
pourrait se débloquer mais qui est
encore un peu bloqué parce que on a un
yatus assez important entre les projets
et la production industrielle hein les
projets sont vraiment très importants la
production
industrielle remonte un tout petit peu
mais enfin c'est extrêmement faible
d'autant plus que si vous regardez si
vous prenez un peu de recul sur
l'industrie ce qu'on voit c'est que la
crise financière de 2008 et la pandémie
qui évidemment ont généré du point de
vue conjoncturel une baisse forte de la
de la production industrielle mais on
voit qu'à chacune de ces crises la la la
base industrielle a rétréci en en
réalité donc il y a pas il y avait pas
simplement un effet conjoncturel et donc
on part vraiment de très bas donc on
voit bien que quelque chose se passe en
France c'est clair il y a une dynamique
une attractivité qui est retrouvée mais
pour le dire très concrètement il y a
pas beaucoup de nouvelles usines ça
contraste avec certains pays si vous
regardez les États-Unis par exemple et
là la question du foncier pour le coup
la différence est vraiment criante aux
États-Unis les les mises en chantier les
surfaces mises en chantier d'usine
explosent à un point qui est assez
inimaginable hein c'est-à-dire que c'est
le rythme de la Chine des années 80 ce
sont des courbes de mise en chantier qui
sont vraiment des courbes à la verticale
donc on voit que c'est possible possible
pour un pays développé mais nous on n'y
est pas encore et donc il faut aller
regarder des blocages qui sont des
blocages à mon sens non fiscaux
et je pense même si ça mériterait d'être
davantage documenté mais que la question
du foncier je le pense parce que tous
les élus locos me le disent tout
simplement la question du du foncier est
absolument centrale alors là encore il y
a des choses qui ont été faites comme le
plan friche par exemple mais vous savez
c'est comme en matière de logement
c'estàdire
en matière de logement la stratégie
aujourd'hui de l'État qui à mon avis
n'est n'est pas la bonne ou qui en tout
cas est comment dire est beaucoup trop
centré sur sur un seul principe consiste
à dire que il vaut mieux rénover le parc
existant plutôt que étendre le parc de
de logement on pourrait y revenir
d'ailleurs parce que je pense que c'est
très lié à la question économique mais
je pense que c'est une idée qui qui est
fausse euh on a un peu le même sentiment
dans le domaine industriel c'estàd que
l'idée c'est de dire il existe il y a
beaucoup de désindustrialisation il
existe des friches il faut essayer de
rebâtir sur ces friches bon sauf que
remettre les friches aux normes c'est
incroyablement coûteux et puis
l'industrie n'est plus la même c'està
dire que une usine qui a été faite au
20e siècle et qui avait besoin je dit
n'importe quoi mais d'une rivière par
exemple c'était quelque chose qui était
très courant au au 20e siècle bah
aujourd'hui n'a peut-être plus du tout
les mêmes types de les mêmes types de
besoins et et les mêmes problématiques
géographiques donc il faut faut qu'on
soit capable de se dire qu'on a besoin
de créer des espaces industriels qui
sont des espaces nouveaux alors je dis
quand même un mot du logement avant de
formuler ma critique vous me voyez venir
du du Zéro artificialisation net mais en
matière de logement
euh je le disais et donc c'est très lié
à l'industrie d'ailleurs à l'économie
hein parce que j'en parlerai dans
quelques instants mais quand vous faites
une gigafactory je prends un exemple qui
est un peu extrême mais vous avez sans
doute besoin de log on imagine quand
même assez mal que àkerer qui est dans
la bonlieue de d'unkerer qui est
aujourd'hui suffisamment de logement par
rapport aux milliers d'emplois qui vont
arriver sur ce sur ce territoire mais
donc les les les deux sont sont très
liés ça voir d'ailleurs aussi avec la
question du chômage au passage dans les
déterminants du chômage structurel
aujourd'hui il y a aussi la question du
logement et au fond le le sujet sur
lequel je veux attirer votre attention
c'est que certes on a un parc de
logement en France qui est très
important quand on regarde les
statistiques internationales on voit que
le nombre de logements par habitant est
élevé et c'est ça qui est à la source de
l'idée selon laquelle on n' pas vraiment
besoin de construire plus sauf que ces
logements sont pas là où sont les
emplois c'est ça la la difficulté et
donc vous pouvez rénover des des
logements j'ai une maison de famille au
à la frontière entre la meuriselle et
les vaaues il y a beaucoup de logements
vacants c'est un endroit qui est
magnifique malheureusement il y a pas
d'emploi et il y a plus de service
public donc on va pas loger les gens là
de toute évidence voyez euh donc il faut
être assez pragmatique de ce point de
vue et se dire qu'on a besoin de
nouveaux logements et qu'on a besoin de
nouvelles usines malheureusement
j'aimerais bien vous dire le contraire
j'aimerais bien vous dire on peut
réindustrialiser et loger les gens sans
artificialiser mais malheureusement je
ne pense pas du tout que ce soit
possible et c'est donc la raison pour
laquelle j'avais déjà formulé beaucoup
de critiques sur cette politique du Zéro
artificialisation net alors heureusement
que le Sénat a amendé et le Sénat a
permis de faire en sorte que ce soit
moins bloquant que ça ne l'était dans la
version originale mais je trouve quand
même très malsin ce dispositif qui part
du haut qui est très centralisé qui é
dicte une règle qui est une règle alors
qui sera décliné qu'il vaut pour tout le
monde alors qu'il sera décliné par
région donc c'est c'est bien enfin une
région c'est quand même grand c'est
quand même une forme de de de
recentralisation et là encore je je
pense que il faudrait documenter ça
davantage
mais beaucoup d'élus locaux me disent
que ils ne peuvent pas accepter des
projets industriels tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le foncier enfin
plus exactement si d'ailleurs ils ont le
foncier mais ils n'ont pas le droit de
l'utiliser c'est c'est ça le problème
parce que le foncier je toujours aussi
un peu agacé quand j'entends dire qu'on
manque de foncier en France parce que
c'est c'est absolument faux on manque de
foncier constructible mais en fait du
foncier il y en a il y en a énormément
voilà donc je je pense quand même que
cette partie de la loi climat résilience
je vous le dis comme je le pense mais
vous m'avez demandé de m'exprimer
franchement je pense que c'est pas
bon je pense en plus que de toute façon
même si c'était bon le rythme est trop
rapide parce que arriver à zéro en 20150
en fait ça demande un effort qui dès
aujourd'hui est un effort qui est
absolument colossal je pense que la
question du du rythme on le voit en ce
moment avec les agriculteurs
pardonnez-moi de faire ce pont avec
l'actualité mais quel est le problème de
ce qu'on demande aux agriculteurs c'est
pas qu'on leur demande de diminuer de 50
% la consommation d'antibiotiques c'est
qu'on leur demande d'ici 2030 c'est ça
la la la difficulté et donc c'est de
tout évidence impossible ENF n'importe
quel agriculteur qui a
une une exploitation un peu conséquente
vous le vous le dira donc je pense qu'il
faut voilà quand même faire très
attention avec cette question des délais
euh voà je pense qu'on fait un peu
d'idéologie et qu'on n'arrive pas encore
bien à mettre le curseur au bon endroit
entre les les équilibres économiques et
ce que l'on voudrait faire idéalement
pour l'écologie notamment en matière
d'artificialisation des soles donc là je
pense qu'on a un vrai qu'on a un vrai
sujet et qui en plus alors pour les
collectivités locales ajoute beaucoup de
complexité de la bureaucratie alors il
peut toujours y avoir des systèmes de
dérogation mais enfin il y a rien de
pire que les systèmes de dérogation les
systèmes de dérogation c'est aller
marchander avec l'État euh donc c'est
contre l'autonomie et ça recrée de la de
la complexité alors je ferai un petit
peu mais je serai beaucoup plus rapide
parce qu'il me reste 2 minutes mais je
ferai le même type de remarque sur les
question en règle générale de de de de
comptabilité extrafinancière
euh je pense que c'est très bien
évidemment qu'un pays comme la France
développe la comptabilité
extrafinancière pour ses entreprises
tous les pays dans le monde le font il y
a une bataille en plus hein pour les
normes donc c'est très bien de le faire
je pense néanmoins qu'on le fait un peu
à la française je connais les immenses
qualités de notre pays aussi c'est ces
petits défauts euh et quand je regarde
les les les directive euh j'y trouve
quand même une une comp alors évidemment
ça elle ne s'applique pas à toutes les
entreprises elle s'applique d'abord aux
grandes entreprises ce qui là aussi est
un grand classique qui présente aussi
des dangers parce qu'on on recrée des
effets de seuil donc donc on a lutté on
a fait des lois notamment la loi pacte
qui était mon sens une très bonne loi
d'ailleurs mais pour lutter contre les
effets de seuil mais on voit qu'on en
recrée hein c'est toujours un petit peu
le problème en France c'est que quand on
diminue les dépenses publiques on recrée
le lendemain de la dépense publique
quand on simpimplifie on recrée de la
norme le le lendemain bon là on a essayé
de supprimer des effets de seuil on est
toujours très créatif pour pour en
refaire et et donc je je pense quand
même que il y a aujourd'hui un consensus
qui est en train de se chiné et je
partage complètement ça autour de l'idée
selon laquelle le le nombre de normes la
complexité est un frein à la croissance
économique et à la prospérité je crois
vraiment que c'est quelque chose qui est
très juste c'est pas d'ailleurs
francofançais hein parce que vous
retrouvez ce en Allemagne par exemple
vous retrouvez exactement le même type
de débat mais enfin il y a un consensus
qui est en train de se dessiner autour
de ça et donc je pense qu'il faut que le
législateur arrive à se dire dire que
dans dans une
loi on peut pas tout prévoir en fait on
peut pas prévoir toutes les éventualités
alors je sais bien que là encore c'est
une tentation surtout pour un pays comme
le nôtre qui est un pays
rationaliste on a vraiment envie de se
dire on va avoir une raquette qui est
sans trou bon mais là vraiment on prend
le risque de l'hyperinflation normative
et on y est
et pour paraphraser le président de la
République qui avait appelé à une pause
normative je suis pas sûr qu'on l'ai
fait hein mais une posuse normative dans
le domaine environnemental et agricole
je pense que cette idée qui n'est pas
appliqué hein mais je je pense que on
pourrait réfléchir au même type d'idée
sur la question des sur la question des
entreprise et puis un tout dernier mot
là vraiment en 15 secondes sur la
question du du financement on pourra
approfondir je pense que nous avons un
très gros sujet en eff faet de
financement des entreprises en Europe
pas seulement en France mais en Europe
de financement en fond propre notamment
je pense que c'est vraiment un frein
pour aller beaucoup plus loin en matière
d'innovation et là le sujet est européen
c'est-à-dire que ce qui nous manque
c'est vraiment un marché du financement
pour l'innovation qui soit harmonisé au
niveau européen qui permettent à des
entreprises qui sont des entreprises
innovantes qui ont déjà bien réussi qui
ont passé le stade de la recherche et
développement et qui s'apprêtent à
industrialiser un produit donc qui ont
besoin de beaucoup d'argent qui ont
besoin de de centaines de millions
d'euros voyez c'est c'est ce type de
montant je pense que là on a encore un
un travail à faire pour développer ce
type de marché un marché vraiment
liquide profond au niveau européen voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction merci merci Monsieur bouou
monsieur desertin nous vous écoutons
merci monsieur le Président donc ravi
évidemment d'être ce matin parmi vous
avec mon cher Nicolas Bouzou donc je
vais essayer de compléter un tout petit
peu enfin en tout cas de de vous
proposer une vision introductive avant
de revenir peut-être vraiment sur les
questions très concrètes qui se posent à
la France euh à mon sens du contexte
dans lequel nous nous trouvons alors
peut-être juste pour dire que on peut
revenir vraiment sur l'élément concret
je précise moi aussi que j'ai créé à la
Sorbonne il y a 11 ans une chair
spécialisée sur l'impact la mesure
d'impact et le financement mais
concernant l'agriculture donc elle
s'appelle finagri et elle a donné lieu
d'ailleurs aussi à la création d'une
structure associative qui s'appelle
finag green c'est-à-dire une structure
de labellisation notation donc peut-être
on aura l'occasion les entreprises
agricoles sont des entreprises et des
petites entreprises pour la plupart mais
avant de revenir peut-être justement sur
ces questions très concrètes et
notamment sur la question du foncier qui
à mon sens sera je crois j'ai cru noter
le premier thème de débat je voudrais
vraiment rappeler au fond le contexte
dans lequel nous nous trouvons et le
contexte dans lequel nous allons nous
trouver et je crois que là lorsque nous
sommes en train d'évoquer ces questions
nous sommes en train de parler de
stratégie la stratégie c'est la vision
de long terme il me semble en tant que
citoyen que ça doit être aussi la
préoccupation du politique
et il est clair que dans la période qui
est la nôtre la vision de long terme est
absolument capitale car probablement
dans l'histoire du monde et vous voyez
je vais me situer bien dans cette vision
globale mondiale nous n'avons jamais été
au seuil d'un changement aussi profond
de mode de vie de mode de consommation
de mode de production en effet nous
avons la convergence extraordinaire on
va dire de plusieurs phénomènes je vais
peut-être en évoquer trois fondamentaux
qui doivent évidemment être en élément
sous-jacent de tous les débats sur la
manière dont on se projette pour la PME
l'entreprise et son financement de
demain le premier phénomène évidemment
c'est celui du dérèglement climatique le
dérèglement climatique est une
problématique économique le dérèglement
climatique signifie quoi signifie que le
modèle économique mondial utilisé à 8
milliards d'humandes nous sommes plus de
8 milliards aujourd'hui et l'humanité
continue de croître en terme
démographique le
le modèle économique utilisé à 8
milliards ne fonctionne pas il ne
fonctionnait pas à 7 milliards il ne
fonctionnait pas à 6 c'est un modèle
économique on va dire qui a dérivé du
modèle industriel qui grosso modo
correspond à un modèle qui a été créé il
y a à peu près de siècle et demi ce
modèle économique est condamné il doit
être modifié il doit être bouleversé et
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi bien
en Comité 21 que dans mes ouvrages je
n'aime pas la notion de transition parce
qu'à mon sens ce changement doit être un
changement très profond et très rapide
l'urgence climatique nous oblige de ce
point de vue quand dans l'histoire nous
avons eu à changer de modèle économique
c'est arrivé très rarement et on va dire
que notre référence absolue c'était
celle il y a de siècles et demi lorsque
le modèle agricole s'est transformé en
modèle industriel le changement de
modèle suppose non pas simplement la
volonté le désir des personnes c'est
important quand même on ne change jamais
parce qu'il faut on ne change jamais
parce qu'on vous y oblige on change
parce que l'on pense que ce sera mieux
après ce changement est intervenu quand
quand on a eu un bouleversement de la
connaissance
scientifique c'est le deuxième phénomène
que je souhaite souligner qui est un
phénomène fondamental nous sommes dans
un bouleversement de la connaissance
scientifique non pas depuis 250 ans ou
non pas depuis 70 ans nous avons eu un
grand bouleversement de la connaissance
scientifique grosso modo entre 1750 et
1950 et nous sommes rentrés maintenant
dans un bouleversement de la
connaissance scientifique depuis à peu
près une vaintaine d'années à la base de
ce bouleversement de la connaissance
scientifique une discipline qui on va
dire irrigue toutes les disciplines
scientifiques actuellement les
mathématiques ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas dans les bouleversements que j'ai
évoqué ce ne sont pas forcément les
mathématiqu qui était à l'œuvre au
départ mais cette fois-ci il est
incontestable que notre monde est en
train de changer par par ce que les
mathématiques nous permettent de
maîtriser ce que l'on appelle les Big
Data les données massives qui dans
toutes les sciences étit jusque-là la
barrière sur laquelle on se htait
aujourd'hui le fait de maîtriser les
mathématiques permet à toutes les
sciences de faire des bondes géants en
1746 non pas dans ce palais mais dans
celui de versaill dans la galerie des
Glaces une expérience va furieusement
amuser la cour si vous me permettez
électriser la cour plus de 100 personnes
en se tenant la main vont être
électrocuté et effectivement un
scientifique amène une solution pour
permettre de faire passer le courant et
là tout le monde va dire mais c'est
incroyable qu'est-ce qui se passe quel
que c'est que cette chose extraordinaire
nous sommes en 1746 personne n'imagine à
l'époque ni le TGV ni le congélateur il
se passera presque un siècle et demi
avant que cette connaissance
scientifique est en train de se propager
dans la science deviennent quelque chose
qui sera proposé au monde économique et
aux citoyens dans leur ensemble nous
sommes dans dans une accélération du
progrès scientifique par rapport à cette
époque qui pourtant est une époque qui a
marqué l'humanité parce que la la
connaissciance scientifique se diffuse
maintenant beaucoup beaucoup plus vite
il y a 3 ans je vous aurai évoqué la
manière dont tous nos collègues en
sciences dur à l'université nous raconte
et quand je dis sciences dur les
mathématiques la physique la chimie la
médecine nous raconte à quel point leur
discipline est en train de changer bon
vous me direz quand on parle de la
médecine et quand on regarde les
avancées prodigieuses à partir des Big
Data app à la génétique combien
peut-être très vite on pourra apporter
des solutions définitives au cancer tout
d'un coup on a l'impression que la
société va vraiment se rendre compte du
progrès scientifique mais je vous disais
3 ans parce qu'évidemment il y a un an
et demi se passe et bien le transfert de
l'électricité non plus des cabinets
scientifiques mais à la vie réelle avec
l'intelligence artificielle générative
nous avons un laboratoire qui s'appelle
open ai aux États-Unis qui décide de
proposer au grand public quelque chose
qui va véritable être utile qui
s'appelle Chad GPT c'est à la fin de
l'année 2022 l'année 2023 va être
l'année de la révolution scientifique
avec d'ailleurs toutes les
interrogations que cela pose du fait de
l'irruption de cet incroyable
bouleversement dans le mode de
fonctionnement dans les questions que
nous nous posons il est évident que nous
n'aurions pas eu les mêmes il y a un an
et demi quand l'intelligence
artificielle ne poait pas le bout de son
nez qui signifie en effet que non
seulement évidemment la connaissance
scientifique devient quelque chose qui
va se concrétiser pour tous mais en
matière économique qui signifie que de
façon brutale nous allons avoir une
transformation absolue de la manière
dont fonctionnent les économies les
entreprises des plus grandes jusqu'aux
plus petites donc cela signifie
évidemment que nous allons devoir avoir
une perspective d'agilité cela veut dire
que ce qui est notre réalité
d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas celle dans 6
mois dans un an et que par conséquent
lorsque l'on va faire de la stratégie
nous devrons intégrer ce facteur
absolument crucial le fait que
l'innovation est entrée dans des phases
de rupture qui vont faire que les
éléments sur lequels nous sommes
aujourd'hui ne sont que des éléments qui
nous permettent un tout petit peu
d'anticiper le futur mais absolument pas
de le représenter totalement je crois
que vraiment il faut insister sur ce
point nous sommes toutes et tous ici
dans cette salle des héritiers de
générations les générations de
l'après-guerre qui au fond ont connu une
stabilité de l'innovation et cette
stabilité d'innovation d'ailleurs a été
à l'origine de la société de
consommation qui est la notôre
aujourd'hui la société de consommation
est né du fait que si dans les années
1890 1900 10 1730 je passe évidemment
sur la parenthèse de la guerre et bien
il fallait peut-être avoir l'électricité
avoir une automobile avoir un
réfrigérateur puis plus tard avoir une
télévision qui était des choses
absolument bouleversante par rapport au
quotidien des humains à partir des
années 1950 il n'y a plus de grandes
innovations et donc là il faudra
remplacer et remplacer le plus vite
possible des biens qui sont finalement
les mêmes que ceux que connaissaient nos
arrières grands-parents des années 1920
1930 donc nous sommes là dans une
innovation qui est radicalement nouvelle
que nos générations doivent apprendre à
découvrir parce que ça n'est pas notre
culture troisème phénomène fondamental
dans lequel nous nous trouvons c'est ce
phénomène de dérèglements Dér règlements
économiques et dérèglements financiers
et lorsque nous allons évoquer tout à
l'heure la question de l'information
extra monétaire vous me permettez
d'utiliser ce terme extra monétaire
plutôt qu'extra financier je crois que
ça doit être évidemment pour nous
représentants de pays euh industriels de
pays développés une des plus fortes
interrogations par rapport au monde qui
est et au monde qui vient le monde
développé le monde des pays occidentaux
est à l'origine à une responsabilité
extrêmement forte dans le dérèglement
climatique que j'ai j'aiévoqué tout à
l'heure mais le monde développé le monde
occidental a une responsabilité
peut-être encore plus forte dans le
dérèglement économique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui en clair je veux
parler de la distorsion jamais vu dans
l'histoire même à l'échelle d'un pays
entre la production de richesse réell
nous avons du point de vue mondial
aujourd'hui en 2024 atteint grosso modo
les 100000 milliards de dollars 104000
milliards probablement avec les
dernières estimations du Femi c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire que nous
passons les 100000 milliards du point de
vue de la production globale nous sommes
dernier chiffre du FMI sans tenir compte
du shadow banking à peu près à 274
680000 milliards de dettes nous avons
une distorsion absolument jamais vue
entre la dette c'est-à-dire la monnaie
en circulation et la richesse réelle ce
qui signifie quoi ce qui signifie que
nous avons un dérèglement qui est un
dérèglement structurel absolument
désastreux je rappelle que un
dérèglement de ce type a été créé par
exemple par la guerre de 141 qui conduit
les grands pays à créé massivement de la
dette que cette dette massive qui n'est
pas retirée du système économique parce
que rien n'est plus compliqué d'enlever
de la monnaie lorsqu'elle est à
l'intérieur du système va créer des
situations de bulle dans les années 20
puis une crise monumentale dans les
années 30 puis une guerre mondiale
malheureusement on connaît le processus
c'est la raison pour laquelle pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale je dis bien la
seconde he quand on dit seconde ça veut
dire qu'il y aura pas de trisè en tout
cas le souhait que je formule pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale on aura en 1944
avant Yalta une réflexion en disant
comment ne pas recommencer et comment ne
pas recommencer c'était clair c'est la
réunion de Breton Woods nous ne devons
pas dérégler le système économique comme
nous l'avons fait précédemment je pense
que effectivement cette réflexion qui a
été fondamental dans les institutions de
bretain Woods a été oublié 30 ans après
c'est-à-dire à partir de 1971 quand
quand les États-Unis vont abandonner la
convertibilité hors du dollar qui est le
début du désordre économique qui ne va
cesser de s'emplifier et qui va
connaître évidemment son paroxisme avec
le covid le covid c'est une création de
monnaie massive par les grands pays
occidentaux alors qu'on ne produit plus
lorsque je vous disais tout à l'heure
que nous avons une distorsion entre le
PIB et la dette l'année de covid
évidemment est une année incroyable de
ce point de vue puisque c'est une année
où on confine ça veut dire qu'on regarde
la télé et qu'on produit plus alors que
l'on va créer de la dette que l'on va
créer de la monnaie avec cette
expression à mon sens qui est très bonne
quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en coûte
cela signifie quoi ça signifie souvent
quand nous participons aux émissions de
télévision les téléspectateurs disent
mais ce quoi qu'il en coûte ça veut dire
que ça va coûter quelque chose c'est
évidemment du bon sens et souvent on dit
ça va nous créer des impôts non non ça
vous crée pas de l'impôt ça vous crée de
l'inflation ça vous crée la perte de
confiance dans la monnaie et ça c'est
bien pire que tout l'inflation disait
Kees c'est l'ethanasie du rentier c'est
l'euthanasie de l'épargne c'est-à-dire
c'est l'euthanasie on mort on meurt de
façon douce mais on meurt quand même de
tout ce qui va être le ressort
fondamental de l'investissement or
l'investissement c'est l'élément
fondamental un de la croissance normale
mais de la croissance encore plus
lorsque l'on doit gérer une révolution
scientifique un bouleversement complet
des modes de fonctionnement économique
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
les banques central du monde occidental
ont décidé de réagir de façon inédite
une augmentation de zéro à 5
c'est-à-dire ça nous fait 500 %
d'augmentation des taux en un an et demi
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait jamais
vu parce qu'il fallait absolument sauver
le soldat épargne ou plus exactement
absolument solder sauver le soldat
investissement donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans cette situation qui est
une situation qu'on ne peut pas
évidemment couper des dérèglements en
termees géopolitiqu que nous sommes en
train de connaître les dérèglements
géopolitique et on le sent lorsque l'on
est dans les assemblées internationales
j'étais encore il y a quelques jours à
Dubaï pour la COP 28 mais on l'a
constaté au moment du G20 on l'a
constaté au moment de la réunion des
bricks on l'a constaté à Paris au moment
de la réunion du FMI nous sommes
aujourd'hui de plus en plus avec une
hostilité manifeste de l'ensemble des
pays non occidentaux je ne sais pas si
le terme Sud global correspondrait bien
parce que je crois que en réalité c'est
Sud Nord est face au ouest face au monde
d'Occident et cette hostilité se
manifeste on le sent dans les éléments
de réunion international ou les délégués
que parfois nous connaissons depuis
longtemps se taisent quand il voit
approcher un Occidental je crois qu'on
doit avoir conscience de ça cette
responsabilité du dérèglement
dérèglement global dans lequel nous
sommes est quelque chose effectivement
qui nous incombe et qui nous oblige à
réfléchir dans la stratégie que nous
allons mettre en place qui ne doit pas
être une stratégie strictement de court
terme ou ne concernant que nos pays et
bien ces trois mécanismes ces trois
phénomènes fondamentaux dans lesquels
nous sommes vous me direz peut-être que
le dérèglement géopolitique serait le qu
me semble être une chance incroyable une
chance incroyable parce que cela va nous
permettre d'aller beaucoup plus vite
dans le bouleversement économique que
nous devons mener et qui se mènera
d'abord sur le terrain c'est-à-dire
d'abord dans les petites entreprises
l'innovation se propage d'abord dans les
petites structures le propre d'une
grande structure c'est d'être grand pour
économiser les coûts une petite
structure à l'agilité nécessaire pour
pouvoir bouleverser complètement sa sa
chaîne de valeur lorsque la France ça a
été la silicone vallée du monde
c'est-à-dire au début du 20e siècle
quand la France a inventé l'aéronautique
a inventé l'automobile a inventé
l'électricité a inventé tout ce qui a
être les vecteurs de valeur du 20e
siècle ce sont des petites entreprises
qui se sont développées ce sont des
petites entreprises qui parfois ont
échoué parce qu'effectivement lorsqu'on
est dans un changement profond nous
connaissons l'échec ce sont des petites
entreprises que la Nation France que les
parlementaires dans cette même assemblée
ont su regarder ont su appuyer on épaulé
je crois que nous sommes dans cette
convergence extraordinaire qui nous
oblige à l'urgence mais qui nous permet
aussi un certain nombre de perspectives
absolument remarquable notamment du
point de vue du financement les éléments
sur lesquels je travaille à titre
personnel d'un point de vue scientifique
donc voilà peut-être l'élément
introductif que je voulais évoquer
devant vous je pense qu'on ne peut pas
avoir une perspective par rapport aux
questions que vous allez traiter qui
serait strictement franco-française et
uniquement associé par exemple à notre
réglementation à notre mode de
fonctionnement nous avons une mission
beaucoup plus forte qui nous incombe et
qui nous incombe non seulement par
rapport à nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants mais par rapport au reste
du monde qui cherch aujourd'hui la
manière de créer la croissance de demain
je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Dessertine merci messieur
on va passer voir nos collègues s'ils
ont des questions à poser je n'en doute
point euh on va commencer par nos
collègues rapporteurs des différentes
missions et notamment alors on va faire
dans l'ordre sur la mission du foncier
économique ù son rapporteur Christian
Klinger et Michel mass en vous demandant
bien évidemment d'avoir des questions
plutôt précises concises de manière à
laisser le plus possible la parole à nos
invités je démarre bon merci Christian
kinger sénateur Duin merci pour vos
propos introductifs c'est c'est plutôt
si on était dans un cirque j'aurais dit
qu'on est dans la haute voltige merci
c'est plutôt
bien avec mon collègue Michel mass nous
je suis cor rapporteur sur une mission
sur le foncier économique en fait les
les entreprises nous ont fait remonter
une forte inquiétude sur cette
difficulté à trouver du foncier donc
elle souhait s'implanter elle souhait
s'agrandir et il y a un certain nombre
de de difficultés qu'on qu'on met en en
évidence dans dans le rapport ils sont
très
divers d'abord trouver le foncier nos a
sont quasiment pleines nos zones
d'activité économique sont sont
quasiment pleines une difficulté avec le
zan puisqu'on a plus le droit de céend
vendre
euh concernant les fonds friches je
ferai le parallèle monsieur Bou à ce que
vous avez dit finalement au niveau du
logement statistiquement en France on a
assez de logement pour pour accueillir t
tous les Français euh statistiquement on
a assez de superficie de friche pour
accueillir toutes les entreprises sauf
qu'elles ne sont pas là où souhait
évidemment s'implanter les les les
entreprises et on le voit aussi
d'ailleurs à travers l'utilisation du
fond friche seul 16 % du fond friche est
utilisé à la reconversion économique
tout le reste est
utilisé pour pour la reconversion dans
le logement parce que faire du logement
c'est aussi un peu plus rentable que que
de développer l'activité économique j'en
viens à ma première question j'en j'en
aurai qu'une la la perception des des
chefs d'entreprise semble semble
confirmé par les chiffres que que nous
sommes procurer que le coût du foncier à
vocation économique est en train
d'augmenter très fort alors que c'était
un petit avantage
compétitif au niveau au niveau européen
alors pensez-vous que ce coût du foncier
représente à terme ou représente déjà un
obstacle à la compétitivité de de notre
économie et comment la France se
situe-elle par rapport aux autres pays
européens ou même sur la map monde si si
vous permettez on va faire le tour de la
des questions sur le sujet et mich
Michel mass si tu as une question bien
sûr en complément de mon collègue
Christian donc seconde puisque
j'en'aurai pas d'autre
euh pour une entreprise effectivement
priorité de trouver le le foncier et on
pourrait se dire qu'éventuellement quand
le foncier ça y est ça démarre on va PIR
engager l'entreprise non c'est juste le
début parfois d'un chemin de croix qui
est
extrêmement difficile et donc je vis
connaître votre position sur la partie
juridique aujourd'hui le risque
juridique pour les entreprise lorsquil
sinstallent des personnes que nous avons
entendu euh et de nos parcours
respectifs on comprend bien que c'est un
frein euh
important vous avez évoqué le zan bien
sûr mais pas que on note qu'il y a un
nombre de recours aujourd'hui euh de
Riverin
d'association justifié ou pas justifier
hein c'est pas ce que je je veux dire
hein je mets simplement le temps
l'entreprise doit répondre à la
réactivité la flexibilité et si déjà au
départ il faut une modification dans un
plan d'urbanisme dans un document
d'urbanisme si en même temps les recours
sont intentés nous sommes sur des délais
qui ne correspondent plus du tout aux
besoins de l'entreprise et donc on voit
des entreprises s'installer à l'étranger
notamment pour car c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus facile donc voilà cette
cette question c'eston donc mesurer les
conséqu économique pardon de ce risque
euh juridique pour pour les entreprises
alors euh quand je vous dis ça j'oublie
pas pour autant toute la partie
aujourd'hui étude des quatre saisons
obligation d'écologue compensation enfin
voilà euh zone humide bien sûr et vous
connaissez tout cela et et aujourd'hui
effectivement ça ne répond pas euh aux
enjeux économiques moi je tenais à vous
remercier également pour vos
interventions qui euh sont venus nourrir
nos travaux avec mon collègue Christian
merci Michel est-ce qu'on aurait
d'autres collègues qui aurait une
question sur le foncier économique voilà
Michel Michel canevé merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais moi également
remercier nos intervenants j'ai beaucoup
apprécié les observations de Nicolas
bouou sur la question du du zan du
foncier je pense comme vous que c'est
assez utopique il
faudrait il fallait effectivement donner
un un coup d'arrêt à la consommation
excessive de fouiller et amener les
acteurs locaux à réfléchir sur de
nouvelles réponses aux besoins
d'urbanisation aujourd'hui mais retenir
l'idée même du Zéro artificialisation
net à l'échéance 2050 me semble me
semble une hérésie totale il faudrait
que dès à présent nous puissions
rectifier cela
c'est-à-dire considérer que le zéro ne
doit pas être l'objectif mais une
consommation modérée doit être
l'objectif parce que sinon je ne vois
pas comment va répondre aux besoins
futurs en matière de développement
économique et ce qui pourrait survenir
c'est ce que Michel mass vient d'évoquer
à l'instant c'est-à-dire que les
entreprises soient obligées d'aller
s'installer à l'extérieur parce que une
fois de plus nous aurons établi en
France une norme qui sera totalement
contreproductive euh par rapport aux
objectifs que nous nous fixons donc je
pense que euh il faudrait se fixer il
faudrait tout dès à présent euh bien
préciser que euh la l'objectif ne doit
pas être le zéro artifation dat et c'est
la question que je voulais vous poser
est-ce que vous partagez cette objectif
ou cette
définition merci Michel
monieur alors je vais prendre les
questions dans l'ordre inverse dans
lequel elles ont été posées ah oui je
suis mais 100 % d'accord avec vos propos
et je pense que l'idée d'une
consommation modérée j'avais pas
réfléchi hein mais je pense qu'il faut
trouver quelque chose autour de ça je
pense que l'idée du zéro à l'horizon
2050 est vraiment enfin quelque chose
auquel on s'astreint ce qui sera sans
doute pas le cas de de nos voisins et de
et de beaucoup de pays et puis en plus
comment dire on peut pas insulter
l'avenir c'est-à-dire que on peut quand
même parfaitement imaginer qu'en
2050 les modes de construction est
beaucoup évolué on construira pas comme
aujourd'hui et donc fixer un objectif si
contraignant à un horizon qui est
lointain
me semble vraiment quelque chose qui est
qui relève un peu voilà d'une vision
extrêmement négative de de l'avenir et
donc je je je pense he que en effet
c'est une vraie question donc je veux
pas donner le sentiment que que je passe
par perte des profit la question de
l'artificialisation parce que c'est pas
le cas on sait que c'est une difficulté
on sait d'ailleurs que les agriculteurs
s'en plaignent aussi he depuis plusieurs
années donc je dis pas du tout qu'il y a
pas de de sujet ce que je critique c'est
la FA dont ça s fait c'està-dire
vraiment de façon univoque extrêmement
centralisée je suis aussi d'accord avec
vous en réalité il faudrait quand même
Eric ver est en train de faire une
mission sur la
décentralisation voilà ça c'est un vrai
sujet c'està-dire que c'est quand même
au territoire et je suis un grand
défenseur de la région mais la région
c'est déjà un peu grand en fait mais
voilà donc c'est au territoire de
regarder ce qu'on peut faire voilà je
pense
que les les les élus locaux sont
parfaitement capables de faire ça
d'autant plus alors là Monsieur le le le
corrapporteur je vais faire le lien avec
votre remarque d'autant plus que les
mécanismes de régulation démocratiqu
sont assez forts parce que pour le dire
clairement les gens veulent pas beaucoup
d'usine et ils veulent pas de logement
donc la contrainte elle est déjà là et
ça je pense que c'est un véritable un
véritable sujet vous posiez une question
qui était est-ce que cette
judiciarisation qui est importante en
France avec une justice en plus qui est
relativement lente donc des des des
recours des jugements qui peuvent
prendre plusieurs années enfin non qui
prennent plusieurs années est-ce que
aujourd'hui c'est documenté est-ce que
c'est un frein à l'implantation de
nouveaux projets alors oui ça l'est et
la réponse est oui puisque au fond quand
on regarde aujourd'hui ce qui
différencie la France en matière
d'attractivité des de nos principaux
concurrents notamment l'Allemagne puce
qu'il y a aussi pas mal de projets
industriels en Allemagne enfin
Royaume-Uni Allemagne voilà pour les
deux principes nos deux principaux
concurrents en matière d'implantation
industrielle on voit très clairement que
la question des délais est celle
aujourd'hui qui fait la différence euh
la la question fiscale a été résolue
elle est encore plus dans depuis
l'adoption de la loi de financeces 2024
notamment pour toute l'industrie verte
avec la mise en place du Crédit Impôt
industrie verte qui à mon avis est un
remarquable outil alors là pour le coup
vous voyez je critique certaines choses
mais ça je pense que c'est un
remarquable outil fiscal qui est copié
sur ce qu'on fait les Américains en fait
he sur ce qu'on appelle l'IRA au aux
États-Unis donc voyez en matière fiscale
je pense vraiment qu'il y a un travail
qui a été fait c'est qui est le bon hein
depuis depu depuis quelques années mais
donc quand vous regardez aujourd'hui là
où on doit faire des progrès c'est
clairement sur cette question là alors
le ministre de l'économie il travaille
je crois que tout le monde a bien
conscience de de de cette question des
délais
excessifs je vais vous dire aussi
quelque chose qui est politiquement
incorrect mais de l'expérience et de ce
que je peux en voir j'ai aussi parfois
l'impression que le juge penche un tout
petit
peu du côté des activistes et pas
toujours du côté du développement
économique donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose dont on doit pouvoir aussi
parler librement parce que la justice
bah fait partie aussi voilà de la de la
République et on doit pouvoir émettre un
un avis un avis là-dessus et mais je
pense qu'on a aussi un travail et donc
ça fait le lien entre vos vos deux
questions il faut qu'on fasse un vrai
travail ça c'est notre job et c'est le
vôre enfin c'est vraiment nous tous
euh sur le le fait que l'usine
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'usine du 19e
siècle c'està-dire que je sais que les
gens et sans doute ce sera le cas pour
moi si on m'annonçait l'arrivée d'une
usine dans mon périmètre de vie je me
poserai un certain nombre de de
questions mais vraiment il faut
expliquer
que les usines aujourd'hui ne sont pas
des usines à charbon qu'elle ne crache
pas de de de la fumée noire que euh on
est dans un pays qui est justement un
pays très normé dans le continent qui
est le plus normé au monde euh et et et
voilà donc je je pense que là il faut
vraiment qu'on fasse ce travail
pédagogique hein qui qu'on n' pas fait
euh suffisamment alors c'est normal
parce que la thématique de la
réindustrialisation elle est assez
récente en réalité mais là je je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on fasse ce
travail-là très en profondeur pour
expliquer à nos concitoyens que euh une
usine en plus dans un pays comme la
France c'est une victoire c'est
formidable et c'est très bien et que
c'est bien pour tout le monde et que
c'est aussi de l'emploi c'est leurs
enfants qui vont travailler là c'est des
commerces qui vont arriver et donc du
coup c'est des services publics c'est
des médecins enfin vous voyez donc je
pense qu'il faut vraiment réexpliquer ça
pour essayer de faire en sorte je sais
pas si c'est un vœux pieux mais que ce
dont vous parlez
c'est-à-dire cette judiciarisation ne
soit pas systématique parce qu'elle
l'est en fait elle est absolument
systématique bon voilà et et je pense
que ça demande aussi beaucoup de courage
du point de vue des politiques hein
c'estàdire que je pense qu'il faut
vraiment assumer euh la la
réindustrialisation euh voilà notamment
face je le disais tout à l'heure à
certains activistes qui arrivent à se
faire entendre qui crient un peu fort
non il faut leur expliquer que on a un
projet qu'on veut que le pays aille de
l'avant qu'on veut qu'il se
réindustrialise euh voilà et donc qu'on
assume parfaitement sans s'en excuser
hein qu'on assume parfaitement d'aller
dans cette dans cette direction et puis
votre dernière question la dernière
question euh sur le coût du foncier euh
oui je pense que c'est un peu tô pour
pour avoir des réponses définitives la
question que vous posez c'est est-ce que
ça va devenir déterminant dans la
compétitivité d'un pays euh moi mon
analyse c'est c'est oui parce que en
fait quand vous regardez un peu la façon
dont a évolué la compétitivité
industrielle ces 10 ou 20 dernières
années on voit que toute la partie coup
de main- d'œuvre qui était déterminante
il y a 20 ans et c'est ça qui a justifié
d'ailleurs qu' est énormément de
localisation des pays occidentaux vers
vers l'Asie par exemple ou vers le
Maghreb ou vers le le cûp de mainœuvre
était déterminant mais quand vous
regardez la comptabilité analytique
d'une usine aujourd'hui ça la part a
beaucoup baissé au bénéfice de
l'amortissement des investissement et
déjà du foncier et donc et et à partir
du moment où les prix du foncier vont
augmenter alors ils vont forcément
augmenter puisque euh on crée de la
rareté et on fait de la
réindustrialisation et il y a des
besoins en matière de lovement donc
alors là c'est vraiment basique on
diminue on restreint l'offre et la
demande augmente donc je peux vous
assurer avec certitude que les prix du
foncier vont vont augmenter est-ce qu'il
vont de donc ça je sais répondre la
question à laquelle je ne sais pas
répondre encore rigoureusement c'est
est-ce que ça va vraiment devenir un
déterminant prioritaire de la
compétitivité industrielle donc je pense
que oui je peux pas vous dire mieux que
je pense que oui mais je vois les
directions que ça ça prend c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs votre
mission est si est si importante je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
pas complètement dans les radars une
dernière remarque qui est un peu
transversale par rapport à tout ce qu'on
s'est dit c'est que je crois que c'était
d'ailleurs dans la dans le courrier que
vous nous avez adressé à à Philippe et
moi au fond est-ce qu'il y a un risque
d'inégalité je dirais entre des grands
projets industriels et des plus petits
projets alors la réponse est oui parce
que en fait les gigafactory ont pas trop
de difficulté pour s'implanter parce
qu'elles ont un tel soutien et notamment
un tel soutien de
que en
réalité ça permet de courtcircuiter un
très grand nombre de difficultés qui va
se poser à je dis n'importe quoi une
usine
d'agroalimentaire ou une ferme tiens
parce que ça vaut aussi pour le domaine
agricole ce que vous dites notamment la
question de la judiciarisation tous les
agriculteurs m'en parlent pour faire une
ferme aujourd'hui c'est la croix et la
bannière notamment du du point de vue
judiciaire donc ça vaut aussi pour pour
l'agriculture et donc oui je pense qu'il
y a ce risque d'inégalité
je pense que ces gigafctory qui viennent
en France c'est formidable je je
soutiens ça à fond je pense que c'est
une excellente nouvelle simplement le
petit risque c'est que ça masque un peu
les difficultés des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire ou des PME pour
faire de nouveaux projets industriels ou
pour pour étendre des des usines
existantes donc ça je pense que c'est
vraiment aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
avoir en
tête sur les les trois questions
là aussi peut-être en en les prenant pas
forcément dans l'ordre où elles ont été
formulées donc sur le zéro
artificialisation nette à l'horizon 2050
donc la vraie question effectivement
c'est de dire est-ce que là nous sommes
dans une norme qui va être amander dont
on dit en réalité on parle de quelque
chose qui va forcément changer parce
qu'il a a pas le choix ou est-ce que on
parle de quelque chose qui va demeurer
c'estàd on peut penser ce qu'on veut la
question c'est de dire est-ce que
ensuite on doit gérer cette
problématique qui ne changera
pas je ne sais pas et là je suis pas
spécialiste comme vous de la chose
politique je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel
point ce texte va être amendé ou non et
là quelle sera la pression de la société
française autour de ces questions je ne
le mesure pas peut-être vous le mesurez
mieux que moi mais on peut partir aussi
dans l'idée que malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas comment il
faudrait dire mais en tout cas en tant
qu'économiste je surtout pas me risquer
dans ce type de de jugement de valeur ça
ne bougera pas et donc ça veut dire quoi
bah ça veut dire qu'il va falloir gérer
cette contrainte et gérer la contrainte
ça veut dire évidemment quand vous avez
parlé de l'ensemble des dispos des des
disponibles que nous avons en terme
justement de zones où nous pourrions
implanter de l'économie je ne suis pas
aussi enthousiaste que Nicolas sur la
question de la réindustrialisation hein
je pense que l'industrialisation est
très très bien d'un point de vue
politique ça marche très bien mais je
pense que on parle d'un ancien monde et
que nous sommes en train de changer
d'humanité et que l'industrie qui nous
semblait formidable aujourd'hui n'est
pas forcément la finalité du
développement économique de demain mais
ça à la limite peu importe parce que de
toute façon on aura toujours besoin
d'entreprise et on aura toujours besoin
d'endroit où les placer donc la question
à mon sens qui doit se poser et de dire
quels sont les types d'entreprise où
avons-nous des disponibilités voyez il
est très paradoxal quand vous êtes en
train de regarder aujourd'hui Paris les
portes de Paris La Défense de voir des
zones industrielles économiques en en
tout cas c'est-à-dire des tours qui sont
vides c'estàdire aujourd'hui les
entreprises ne veulent plus c'est pas
qu'elles veulent plus c'est que les gens
ne veulent plus et là quand Nicola
évoque le fait que les personnes ne
veulent pas on ne peut pas dire ah bah
oui mais non mais de toute façon il
faudra qu'elle plie non non c'est pas
vrai si nous avons des tendances de fond
de la population il va falloir
évidemment les regarder et dire où la
population veut vivre et quand on évoque
le logement cette question est
absolument cruciale donc où elle veut
vivre et par conséquent où elle veut
travailler
donc ça signifie effectivement que nous
avons beaucoup de questions à poser sur
les zones disponibles aujourd'hui et sur
la manière dont on pourrait
éventuellement proposer à une population
de s'intégrer vous voyez on n'est pas du
tout dans de la mesure de court terme
immédiate c'est-à-dire on est dans une
réflexion à mon sens qui doit être
fondamentale aujourd'hui sur
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire sur lequel
nous sommes est une se de logique de
rail provenant de notre développement
antérieur c'est-à-dire la fatalité c'est
la grande ville la très grande ville
d'ailleurs Paris en fait qui est le
Grand Paris la grande perspective de
développement du des 30 prochaines
années pour la France et puis de
quelques autres très très grandes villes
qui vont par définition capter toute la
population d'accord et si ce scénario
n'est pas le bon et si ce scénario
commençait déjà à être mise en question
non seulement chez nous mais dans tous
les autres pays notamment européens donc
ça signifie évidemment que quand on est
en train de réfléchir à l'endroit où il
va falloir pouvoir implanter des
entreprises de tout type je répète bien
de tout type et pas simplement des
usines on doit avoir ce type de
réflexion et on doit se poser la
question attention est-ce que nous ne
sommes pas simplement là dans une sorte
de réaction
immédiate des villes que je connais bien
notamment dans le Sud-Ouest disent
effectivement je n'ai plus de foncier
disponible pour des entreprises je fais
comment je fais comment je regarde
peut-être les villes qui sont des villes
moyennes qui sont finalement pas si loin
et dans lesquelles peut-être on peut
avoir des perspectives intéressantes
mais qui signifie alors qu'on doit avoir
une réflexion d'aménagement du
territoire complet et là bien sûr je
pense que ce que ce qu'évoquait tout à
l'heure Nicolas sur la question des
services publics sur la question de la
présence de l'État sont des questions
fondamentales elles doivent accompagner
la question de l'endroit où on va
développer les entreprises alors
peut-être évidemment que vous allez me
dire la loi va être modifié va être
bouleversé nous aurons une une majorité
pour changer complètement cette approche
et évidemment tout ce que je suis en
train de vous dire peut-être changera
dans la question immédiate mais ne
changera pas nécessairement dans la
vision de plus long terme que l'on doit
avoir par par rapport à cela je crois
qu'il y a de deux facteurs fondamentaux
qu'on doit avoir à l'esprit sur le
nouveau modèle qui est en train de se
développer le nouveau modèle au niveau
mondial du point de vue économique je
crois qu'il faut vraiment l'intégrer
parce que même si nous sommes rétifs
même si nous sommes par nature
conservateur conservateur ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que finalement on
préférait que tout change pour rien ne
change le confort c'est au fond nos
repères le nouveau modèle est un modèle
décentralisé déconcentré la logique dans
laquelle nous rentrons c'est une logique
d'éclatement
horizontale alors que le modèle
industriel qui était le modèle du 19e et
du 20e siècle c'était un modèle de
concentration il fallait concentrer pour
produire au même endroit et pour
consommer au même endroit la logique
dans laquelle nous rentrons à tout point
de vue est une logique d'aplatissement
et donc évidemment du point de vue de la
manière dont on doit envisager
l'implantation des nouvelles entreprises
il doit y avoir cette réflexion qui doit
se faire et qui doit forcément croiser
les problématiques immédiates que le PE
on peut avoir quand il s'agit
d'implanter les entreprises alors
problématiques immédiates là pour le
coup je reviens sur vos
questions il est évident que la France a
un réel problème et le zéro artificiel
artificiel net zan nous le pose sur la
surtransposition des normes nous avons
un problème de surtrposition des normes
et là quand on dit ça ça veut dire qu'on
parle juste des pays européens ça veut
dire que nous avons un problème de
compétitivité
incroyable parce que c'est ant on va
dire d'arriver à ce
niveau-là un problème de compétitivité
en rajoutant de la complexité à tout
acteur économique à chaque fois
d'ailleurs avec des très bonnes raisons
c'està-dire du point de vue politique on
expliquera toujours pourquoi on a dû on
a choisi d'aller plus loin que les
voisins sauf qu'en terme compétitif
effectivement c'est tragique et ça
signifie qu'à chaque fois quand vous
évoquez un par exemple notre approche en
terme de foncier est-elle plus stricte
que nos voisins si oui c'est clair c'est
que le prix va augmenter plus fortement
et là par rapport à ce qu'on vient de
dire quand Nicolas vous dit c'est
évident ça va monter le prix va monter
il faut rajouter le foncier ne doit pas
être la priorité absolue des
investissements des entreprises de
demain nous allons avoir des
investissements extrêmement
coûteux absolument passionnants parce
que porteur d'une nouvelle croissance
mais qui signifie que le foncier
l'endroit où vous implantez devrait être
l'élément qui au fond est très vite
réglé et doit surtout pas être l'élément
qui va augmenter les coûts donc là nous
avons vraiment une question si nos
normes excessives nous conduisent à
avoir un coût excessif de ce qui
normalement devrait être un
investissement secondaire alors là c'est
dramatique et là effectivement nous
devons réagir très très vite et avoir
des comparaisons et regarder ce qui se
passe notamment et là c'est intéressant
de le voir dans les zones frontalières
hein et de regarder si en effet très
vite on voit des projets porteurs qui
peuvent se poser de l'autre côté de la
frontière même pas forcément pour des
raisons fiscal mais parce que en effet
le coût je dirais qui doit être le coût
le plus faible c'est-à-dire le coût fond
du foncier deviendrait un élément
déterminant pour le choix de
l'entreprise et puis évidemment par
rapport à cela quand vous ajoutez la
question juridique je crois que oui en
effet nous avons de ce point de vue un
vrai problème alors je vais surtout pas
rentrer comme à osé le faire Nicolas sur
la question de l'orientation de la
justice je pense que en terme économiste
je ne m'y prononce pas en revanche nous
avons une vraie question c'est la
question du temps la question du temps
de la justice est une question
fondamentale nous avons beaucoup trop de
temps
je dirais en France même en Europe plus
largement je rappelle que par rapport à
toutes les révolutions que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure l'Europe n'est pas dans
l'intelligence artificielle générative
que nous avons une entreprise qui est
apparue dans les SEP magnifiques on
appelle les capitalisations des SEP des
SEP entreprises qui sont plus
importantes que la France l'Allemagne la
Grande-Bretagne l'Italie l'Espagne
c'est-à-dire la 7e qui vient de rentrer
l'anne dernière Nvidia Nvidia aurait pu
être européen c'est une entreprise qui
vaut 1500 milliards de dollars elle
n'est pas européenne et donc là on doit
se poser la question pourquoi les
Européens ne développent pas comment ça
se fait que nous ayons les compétences
et que nous développions pas je pense
que la question du financement va venir
très vite parce qu'à mon sens elle est
centrale mais une question qui se pose
aussi c'est la rapidité il est évident
que par rapport à ce que nous disions
tout à l'heure l'agilité est
fondamentale le temps de la justice qui
est un temps technique qui est pas juste
la nécessité philosophique du juge le
temps technique de la justice européenne
et singulièrement française est beaucoup
trop long ça veut dire que nous devons
avoir un investissement massif dans
l'outil technique à disposition du Juge
et qu'effectivement les recours sont
évidemment quelque chose de normal du
point de vue citoyen c'est quelque chose
de sain dans une démocratie mais ils
doivent être traité en urgence en
urgence parce que le temps économique se
raccourcit dans un temps d'innovation
fondamentale nous ne pouvons plus nous
permettre d'avoir 4 ans avant de lancer
un projet les projets qui mettent 4 ans
avant de sortir de terre sont des
projets qui qui sont obsolètes quand ils
sont produits nous devons avoir cette
idéelà et que même un an un an et demi
c'est long néanmoins un an un an et demi
c'est possible euh j'avais discussion
hier et je ne parlerai pas de la
personne mais d'un grand projet au
portes de Paris qui a mis moins d'un an
et demi pour être constitué avec
solution pour le foncier avec toutes les
autorisations et aucun recours c'est
possible donc ça veut dire aussi que
nous devons regarder les bonnes
pratiques euh les bonnes pratiques
autour de nous et regardz comment s'en
inspirer et optimiser au plus vite ces
questions qui doivent être des questions
normalement annexes le changement de
modèle normalement c'est pas la manière
dont on va contourner les problèmes pour
arriver simplement à trouver un endroit
où on implante une
entreprise merci messieur on va
maintenant demander à nos deux collègues
rapporteurs sur la mission CSRD
anneesophie roman et Marion Canales une
petite question
chacuneer juste
une
question pour revenir à alors très
rapide parce qu'on a encore deux
missions derrière qui veulent poser des
questions et et il nous reste par une
demi-heure je trouve qu'on est pas on
est rentré rapidement dans les
contraintes avec le le le zan on a la
chance d'avoir deux esséistes en face de
nous alors essayons essayons de nous
projeter sur le Nouveau Monde est-ce que
vous pouvez nous caractériser le nouveau
monde que nous avons devant nous on a
connu les 30 glorieuses on a connu les
grand glandeuse où on a complètement
perdu la valeur du travail qu'on a
désacralisé l'entreprise qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans quelque chose qui nous
perd en terme comment vous imaginez dans
quel monde vous imaginez demain le monde
économique et le monde d'entreprise
parce que c'est celui-là qu'il faut
imaginer avant même de commencer à
lister les contraintes moi j'aimerais
bien que vous nous donniez
rapidement votre vision de dans quel
contexte on est appelé à demain faire de
l'économie dans ce dans ce nouveau
monde alors c'est une question qui est
très large on a 30 secondes c'est ça
demande quand même du temps je peux
répondre dans 30 secondes vraiment 30
secondes non mais je peux répondre dans
30 secondes parce que je voudrais
vraiment et et bah peut-être que
Laurence Garnier a une question dans le
même sens et puis et puis après voilà 30
secondes vraiment pour gagner du temps
président dans le prolongement de la
question de notre collègue vous avez
brossé un certain nombre de défis
majeurs qui nous attendent à tout
niveaux
financiers évidemment
climatique je voulez avoir aussi votre
regard sur le défi démographique qui me
paraît tout aussi majeur avec des
projections qui varient du simple au
double en fonction des des des des
sociologues des démographes on parle de
10 milliards à horizon 2050 de 4
milliards à horizon
200 peut je crois qu'on peut pas faire
sans ce défi- làà également pour se
projeter dans les les décennies à
venir alors juste je je le dis toujours
mais c'est bien de vous présenter aussi
donc Laurence Garnier qui est
sénateur de la V Loire Atlantique Loire
Atlantique et et et sénateur bven qui
est du
morbillant je vais répondre très
rapidement à ces deux à ces deux ouais
bien sûr sur la première question on
entre dans un monde qui est celui de la
destruction créatrice accélérée
c'est-à-dire que l'accélération de
l'innovation technologique les
contraintes li au réchauffement
climatique tous les chocs géopolitiques
qui s'accélèent et qui ont un impact
déterminant sur l'économie font que
l'économie est devenue une espèce de
variable justement en quelque sorte euh
du de choc exogène du climat des guerres
enfin des tensions géopolitiques de
l'innovation qui arrive extrêmement vite
et donc on a une accélération absolument
incroyable des une accélération
absolument incroyable des changements
voilà qui est quelque chose avec lequel
la France est pas très à l'aise parce
que c'est plutôt un pays planificateur
plutôt un pays de de de de de stabilité
mais qui a un immense avantage c'est que
ça ouvre en permanence des portes et des
opportunités du point de vue économique
il y a tellement de changement que voilà
il y a toujours des choses nouvelles des
opportunités nouvelles sur la question
démographique je vais être très rapide
parce que pour moi en fait c'est
vraiment un problème migratoire la
question démographique parce que le le
problème démographique est un problème
au fond de de répartition de la
démographie en France la population va
se stabiliser elle va peut-être baisser
au Nigéria à laigos on va avoir 40
millions d'habitants 400 millions
d'habitants au Nigéria dans un pays qui
n'arrive pas qui arrive à régler aucun
de ses problèmes pour le dire très très
clairement et donc on va avoir des des
des phénomènes migratoire accentué par
le réchauffement climatique qui vont
être absolument colossaux donc la
question démographique à mon sens est
moins une question au fond qui consiste
à se dire est-ce qu'on est trop et
cetera parce que de toute façon on peut
on peut pas on peut pas y faire
grand-chose et en plus je peux pas
développer mais je ne pense pas qu'on
soit trop en revanche la question des
mouvements de main de des mouvements de
population vatre mais mais colossal et
au fond les débats qu'on a en France sur
l'immigration qui sont des débats très
vifs en ce moment pour moi c'est un un
entraînement voilà par rapport à ce défi
qui va être qui qui va sera une
puissance la puissance 10 dans à
l'horizon de 10 ou 15 ans donc vite 30
secondes aussi donc bah les deux
questions à mon avis se
recoupent l'humité que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui pas uniquement en Occident
du point de vue mondial est une humanité
différente de celle que nous avons connu
pendant 250 ans en clair pendant 250 ans
l'humanité est une humanité qui avait
vaincu la mortalité infantile et des
femmes au moment de l'accouchement
c'estàd une humanité jeune et donc
l'industrie a correspondu le
développement de l'industrie a
correspondu au besoins d'une humanité
jeune donc dans la salle vous êtes tous
très jeunes mais moi qui commence à
vieillir plus on vieillit moins on
consomme de produits physiques moins on
a besoin d'industrie plus on a besoin de
service nous allons avoir une humanité
maintenant qui sera une humanité de plus
en plus plus vieillissante et qui va
donc complètement bouleverser le modèle
économique dans lequel nous sommes le
modèle économique en particulier d'un
pays comme la France va être un modèle
économique devant intégrer de plus en
plus une population âgée et donc ça je
crois que du point de vue mondial
l'élément fondamental sur lequel on doit
travailler c'est cette idée-là et je le
répète évidemment les pays avancés sont
les plus concernés mais beaucoup
d'autres le sont également la Chine est
devant un problème majeur d'humanité
vieillissante et
la Chine qui a développé une logique
industrielle de pays jeunes va se
trouver très très vite confronté à une
question de besoin de pays âgés ce qui
est pas du tout le même par rapport aux
projections démographiqu donc grosso
modo on parle 10 milliards non pas 2050
mais à 2080 aux alentour de 2085 même on
pense he que on attendrait je pense et
là à titre personnel là pour le coup
quand on quitte l'approche économique et
qu'on se dit qu'est-ce que je souhaite
je souhaite qu'on soit bien au-dessus
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui nous
avons une distorsion beaucoup trop forte
qui est d'ailleurs la première cause de
migration entre les pays pauvres qui
vont avoir une espérance de vie
extrêmement faible le Nigéria dont
parlait Nicolas 54 ans d'espérance de
vie 220 millions d'habitants aujourd'hui
54 ans d'espérance de vie c'est
insoutenable d'ailleurs le Premier
ministre indien a de façon assez
indirecte mais intéressante dit tant que
j'aurais une espérance de vie à 70 ans
en Inde je serai obligé d'utiliser le
charbon je trouve que c'était une sorte
de résumé très très rapide et
intéressant en disant les pays qui ont
une espérance de vie beaucoup plus
faible que la nôtre demandent un
développement pour avoir l'espérance de
vie des pays occidentaux ce qui signifie
évidemment une augmentation
démographique l'hypothèse le modèle de 4
milliards qui a fait un peu de bruit est
un modèle ultra minoritaire dans lequel
on est toute chose égal par ailleurs en
disant donc on va avoir un certain
nombre d'effondrement de natalité 1
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on observe pour
le moment on est avec par exemple sur
l'Afrique une natalité extrêmement forte
et avec une attente de tous les pays
pauvres d'une augmentation de leur
espérance de vie je rappelle que les
hommes français viennent de dépasser en
2023 les 80 ans on a eu une augmentation
de l'espérance de vie sur 2023 de 0,6
années qui est l'augmentation de
d'espérance de vie la plus forte depuis
plus de 50 ans on avait on était plutôt
sur 01 02 jusque là 06 l'année dernière
formidable nous allons être de plus en
plus
vieux merci Monsieur de sertine merci
Monsieur bouou on va parler un peu
CSRD merci oui merci on va essayer de
faire conc on va faire
concis merci messieur en tout cas pour
la qualité de vos interventions alors
bien évidemment en tant que corapporteur
de la mission sur la directive de la
CSRD j'ai été particulièrement
intéressé par votre vision de notre
monde en transformation absolue parce
qu'il s'agit bien de ça la CSRD et
d'accompagner les entreprise vers cette
transformation et et du coup on se rend
bien compte que la CSRD n'est pas une
fin en soi elle doit être un outil
stratégique pour pour les entreprises je
ne suis pas sûre qu'elle soit perçu
comme ça aujourd'hui comme je pense
qu'elle est plus vue comme une
contrainte plutôt qu'un outil alors que
les enjeux sont sont importants donc ma
question est selon vous est-ce que les
enjeux sont suffisamment clairire pour
les
entreprises les entreprises sont-elles
prêtes y compris financièrement parce
qu'en plus il y a un coût donc avoir
cette vision euh stratégique et globale
et et emmener les entreprises je pense
que le coût pourrait être
euh plus euh enfin moins difficile si on
on en comprend vraiment les enjeux les
enjeux stratégique et et surtout comment
donner à la CSRD cette étof ce corps euh
qui permet euh d'être dans la stratégie
et non de devenir un simple outil de
renseignement voilà c'est peut-être trop
long mais en tout cas il faut vraiment
que je pose ces
questions alors merci me concernant la
CSRD donc c'est un nouveau cadre
normatif pour le rapport de durabilité
on a parlé finalement des enjeux de
durabilité dans le monde de l'entreprise
à travers toutes les tous les sujets que
vous avez abordés ça concerne alors
monsieur bouou vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit c'est un effet de seil qui est qui
serait réintégré mais ça concernera
quand même 50000 entreprises mais
surtout 75 % du chiffre d'affaires
européen donc on est quand même sur une
massification de de
l'enjeu est-ce que pour pour vous c'est
réellement des normes trop importantes
avec des
surtranspositions trop en droit français
puisque vous l'avez évoqué ce ce sujet
et un frein à la compétitivité parce que
on a quand même tendance à à se poser la
question que ça va être un vrai outil de
pilotage pour le changement de paradigme
qu'il va falloir que les entreprises
mettent en place avec tout toutes les
enjeux que vous avez évoqué sur le
foncier économique et sur les les enjeux
et aussi pour garder de l'attractivité
des salariés puisqu'il y a aussi une
quête de sens des des salariés dans les
entreprises et donc pour pour
accompagner ça par ailleurs ça permettra
aussi de tirer les les conséquences des
lacune précédente d'absence de standard
et de normes donc au lieu d'être une
surnorme ça peut également être facteur
éventuellement d'égalité entre les
entreprises que tout le monde
renseignera la même chose le même cadre
et renforcera ce ce finalement ce
mouvement de de compétitivité entre
elles mais c'est une
question merci il y a-t-il d'autres
questions sur sur la CSRD monsieur
dertine est-ce que vous pouvez pardon
CSRD il faut qu'on se tienne quand même
un petit peu monsie le président juste
monsieur desessertine vous avez monsieur
dertine vous avez indiqué vous parlez
plutôt d'extra monétaire plutôt d'extra
financier mais vous n'avez pas développé
je pense que si en toute fin on a un peu
de temps on serait preneuse de ce ce
détail si elle est très courte
ou une question on trcoute merci de oui
Jérome Daras sénateur du P decalé merci
de vos exposés à la fois concis et clair
euh on comprend bien que la difficulté
c'est la gestion de la transition d'un
modèle vers un autre d'un modèle ancien
vers un modèle nouveau donc comment
précisément c'est un sujet d'abord
politique mais aussi économique je ne
doute pas que vous y avez réfléchi
comment dégager les ressources et moyens
nécessaires pour à la fois faire
accoucher le Nouveau Monde et préserver
l'ancien le temps nécessaire le dernier
changement de modèle que nous avons vu
c'est celui de de l'Union
soviétique passer d'un système
administré à un système libéral et ça
s'est très mal
passé
euh alors les questions d'ailleurs à mon
avis se peuvent se recouper tout à
l'heure j'ai dans mon exposé liminire
évoqué l'écart 100000 milliards de PIB
280000 milliards de dettes donc dans
l'histoire première solution vous
ratiboisez la dette c'est-à-dire en
réalité vous vous faites un reset ça
c'est une catastrophe économique et ça
se finit en général pas catastrophe
géopolitique pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité du fait de
l'apparition de ce progrès technologique
et de cette obligation de le mettre en
œuvre parce que nous devons changer de
modèle on a la possibilité d'une autre
solution c'est une sortie par le haut
c'est-à-dire créer 200000 milliards de
PIB pour réégaliser si vous voulez
l'équilibre fameux équilibre économique
a été pendant longtemps le cœur des
questions théoriques en économie euh
donc entre le PIB et la création
monétaire donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut que nous trouvions de la
richesse nouvelle qui va être qui va
contrebalancer la monnaie que nous avons
créé cette richesse elle ne peut pas
être évidemment et ça c'est un des vrais
soucis européens parce que c'est quelque
chose qui n' a absolument pas notre
culture elle ne peut pas être
directement associé chiffre d'affaires
Bénéfic dividende qui est la logique
sans arrêt qui est la nôtre qui est la
raison pour laquelle on n' pas développé
un Amazon on n pas développé Netflix
nous sans arrêt on dit mais cette
entreprise perd de l'argent donc comment
peut-elle continuer à gagner de la
valeur parce qu'en fait on va avoir une
représentation de valeur complémentaire
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit extra
mononétaire voyez la monnaie ce sont les
échanges et là nous sommes en train avec
l'information extrraamonétaire de
représenter une autre valeur en clair
cette valeur elle provient de quoi elle
provient du fait que vous allez
maintenant valoriser nous allons
maintenant valoriser la manière dont son
produit la manière dont on produit est
complémentaire de la production
elle-même et je dirais là nous sommes
presque dans une situation où nous
allons avoir deux circuits complètement
séparés le circuit de la rotation
d'activité normale et le circuit de
cette valorisation de la manière dont on
produit qui peut-être un circuit
financier à part qui va donc évidemment
être un circuit financier ayant pour
vocation de financer de l'investissement
c'est-à-dire on voit très bien la
monnaie disponible se précipite vers ce
qui peut apparaître quelque chose comme
étant une valeur nouvelle peut-être
quand même par rapport à cette notion de
manière dont on produit je crois que
nous la concevons très bien à l'envers
vous fabriquez des des baskets avec une
virgule rouge vous avez 225 230 millions
de consommateurs votre entreprise vaut
très cher vous avez le produit vous avez
le consommateur on apprend que les
baskets sont produit par des enfants
d'un seul coup d'un seul la valeur de
votre entreprise s'effondre c'estàdire
que on voit bien que la valeur
économique
du mode de production peut-être quelque
chose qui complète négativement mais
maintenant positivement l'élément qui
représente je dirais l'activité de base
donc ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
l'information extamonétaire c'est en
réalité donc extraonétaire c'est-à-dire
voyez dans le circuit nouveau c'est de
regarder comment on peut valoriser la
manière dont on produit cette
valorisation nous permettant formidable
c'est exactement ce dont on a besoin de
rééquilibrer ce système totalement
déséquilibré d'un point de vue financier
et voyez ce déséquilibre tout d'un coup
devient une chance parce qu'on va avoir
on a un intérêt énorme de tous les
investisseurs c'est-à-dire ceux qui
disposent de monnaie et qui disent mais
où il y a-t-il de la valeur et s'il ne
le trouvent pas il crée de la bulle il y
a pas 36 solutions il crée de la bulle
c'est-à-dire de l'inflation au départ
circonscrite puis qui s'étend donc
effectivement là on a quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est la possibilité
d'attirer du financement disponible sur
ces informations extrraamonétaires et
donc je pense qu'effectivement
l'information extamonétaire est le grand
défi de notre époque et notamment des
petites entreprises vous dites 50000 je
ne suis pas d'accord bien sûr je suis
d'accord avec vous he sur le principe et
sur la loi mais en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus parce que nous allons
avoir et justement c'est là que c'est
intéressant le truchement des banques
les banques qui sont obligées elles de
se conformer à la CSRD doivent
évidemment faire l'analyse de l'élément
extra financier de leur placement de
leur créances et leur créan évid
évidemment concerne notamment les
petites entreprises c'est-à-dire que on
a ce vecteur qui est un vecteur
extraordinairement vertueux qui est le
vecteur du financement quand nous sommes
en train d'évoquer cette contrainte je
suis d'accord avec vous qu'aujourd'hui
elle est contra elle est envisagée
uniquement d'un point de vue et
strictement d'un point de vue d'une
contrainte réglementaire supplémentaire
qui affolle d'ailleurs tout le monde
depuis l'entreprise jusque au
commissaire au compte ou aux experts
comptables qui disent le commissaair au
compte qui disent je va falloir je
certifie de l'information extra
mononétaire je sais pas comment faire
hein c'est pas mon job et donc là
effectivement nous avons la contrainte
mais nous avons derrière cet énorme
avantage c'est-àdire cette idée qu'il y
a la captation d'un financement avec en
face une valeur réelle et je crois
vraiment que quand on voit à quel point
quand on a parlé j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure d'inflation nous devons bien
nous rendre compte que l'inflation c'est
pas les prix qui monte c'est la monnaie
qui perd de la valeur c'estàdire c'est
la perte de confiance dans la monnaie
qui est le le grand événement des deux
dernières années le fait que dans le
monde soudain on s'est dit en fait la
monnaie est quelque chose de non fiable
et ça cet élément là il est est rentré
dans la tête de tous les citoyens
économiques du monde qui même quand vous
étiez en Argentine vous aviez une
monnaie qui valait rien ou qui était
très compliqué enfin j'espère que amis
argentins ne vont pas m'en vouloir ont
placé son éparne en dollar en disant il
y a une monnaie quelque part qui vaut
quelque chose nous avons eu maintenant
cette perte de confiance dans la monnaie
l'information extramonétaire est
formidable parce que ce n'est plus de
l'information monétaire sujette à
caution c'est l'information réel et là
évidemment se pose la question qui vient
juste après quand on dit en fait c'est
quelque chose de formidable ok on fait
comment ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'en réalité il va falloir collecter de
la représentation de cette valeur en
clair ça s'appelle de la data ça
s'appelle de la donnée ça s'appelle de
la data quand on parle effectivement en
Fran anglais ça s'appelle de la data qui
donc est le vraie question est la vraie
problématique des entreprises il va
falloir et là moi je présente ça l'autre
jour j'étais avec des Mercières des
dames qui avaient des merceries qui me
disent on n'est pas concerné par ça bah
si bien sûr vous êtes mais comment ça il
faut qu'on montre la manière dont on
produit oui vous devez montrer que vous
êtes en train de changer la manière dont
vous produisez ah mais on change oui
c'est vrai je fais plus du tout le
métier comme ma mère qui m'a transmis le
commerce et ben ça il faut que vous
arriviez à le transformmer en data ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que quand
j'ai mis par exemple des ampoules à
faible consommation c'est de la data il
va falloir maintenant que vous
représentiez votre baisse de
l'électricité donc vous allez avoir la
première question identifier la data qui
me prouve que je crée la valeur montrer
qu'elle est fiable savoir où je la stock
regardez comment cette data va me
permettre non pas en elle-même
aujourd'hui les entreprises tous les
secteurs d'activité l'agriculture
compris dire la data ça vaut cher on
comprend c'est le grand vecteur de
création de valeur de demain mais au
fond personne n'a bien compris comment
ça all créer de la valeur c'est cré de
la valeur par du financement par du
financement qui va pouvoir se
rentabiliser par cette création de
valeur supplémentaire et là encore si je
vais jusqu'au bout ça veut dire que
derrière cette question un on a la
question la data comment on la stock
comment on la représente comment on
l'utilise comment on caractérise la
création de valeur on aura des
catastrophes de ce point de vue parce
qu'il y aura évidemment de la data qui
sera de la data fausse ou de la data qui
sera incomplète et donc on aura des
scandales forcément quand on change de
modèle on a ces sortes d'ajustements qui
sont compliqués mais on va avoir aussi
de ce point de vue justement des
questions sur la validité de la data qui
va être absolument cruciale et qui va
devoir être faite de la façon la plus
neutre possible et puis pour terminer le
financement qui va être attiré par cette
création de valeur ne recevra pas des
dividendes ne sera pas associé au
bénéfices et donc il faut que ce
financement puisse avoir une rentabilité
qui se fasse indépendamment du circuit
traditionnel que nous européens nous
privilégions je dis nous Européens parce
que je pense que nous sommes au bord de
la guerre de Sécession aux États-Unis
c'est-à-dire Est-Ouest l'Est américain
est toujours dans l'ancien modèle et et
lui aussi sur dividendes ou plutôt
chiffre d'affaires Bénéfic dividende
l'Est l'Ouest pardon la côte ouest qui
est la côte de la technologie c'est
l'endroit du Nasdaq c'està-dire le
marché dans lequel on va le risqui on
valorise le bilan l'incorporel de
l'entreprise c'est celui qui a permis de
développer les ses magnifiques que
j'évoquéis tout à l'heure et ça c'est
une vraie question qui se pose aux
Européens les Européens n'ont pas
constitué on va dire le circuit
financier qui va permettre de valoriser
l'information extamonétaire c'està-dire
qu'on a commencé par donner je dirais la
matière première dont on a besoin pour
avoir cette valorisation nouvelle mais
on a la matière première on n pas
l'usine qui sert à la transformer et ça
c'est une question fondamentale comment
nous allons pouvoir ultra vite
intéresser un financement à ces
informations extamonétaires en disant
l'intérêt va effectivement ensuite
boucler alors les banques en ce moment
évidemment le font c'est-à-dire que la
Banque centrale européenne va dire aux
banques quand vous avez un très bon
client avec de la très bonne information
extamonétaire c'est un taux d'intérêt
zéro zéro parce qu'effectivement là
c'est pas grave de créer de la monnaie
on est sûr qu'il y a la valeur et
probablement plus qu'on croit donc par
rapport à l'équilibre que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure ça il y a aucun problème je le
répète attention les petites entreprises
ça doivent être les cibles prioritaires
le Nasdaq il est d'abord fait pour des
petites entreprises pas pour les géants
les géants ils sont dans la logique
combien j'ai de Bénéfic combien j'ai de
coût par raort à mon chiffre d'affaires
donc là on est bien dans quelque chose
que l'Europe doit inventer sur laquelle
la France doit se poser la question
parce que nous n'avons absolument pas
cette culture du bilan et cette culture
de l'incorporelle qui va avec
l'extrraamonétaire qui par définition
est une information
bilancielle merci Monsieur desertin
monsieur bouo je vais répondre à la
question que vous avez posée sur les
ressources parce qu'en effet c'est
transition coûte très cher beaucoup de
rapports ont été publiés publiés
là-dessus la transition écologique par
exemple c'est au minimum 30 milliards
d'euros par an donc c'est des montants
qui sont qui sont conséquents je crois
qu'il y a deux choses à à répondre à
cela il y a une première réponse qui est
purement d'ordre macro-économique he
c'està-dire qu'en réalité on a besoin
collectivement pour financer tout ça de
dégager davantage de ressources donc
c'est la question de la croissance tout
simplement qui elle-même est alimentée
par au fond combien de gens travaillent
est-ce qu'on travaille beaucoup est-ce
qu'on est formé et cetera et d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle j'ai soutenu la
réforme des retraites c'était moins une
réforme d'équilibre financier des
retraites que cette idée qui consiste à
dire qu'il faut qu'on s'organise
collectivement pour dégager travailler
plus dégager davantage de ressources
pour financer notamment un certain
nombre de de de de transitions don dont
celle-ci la la la la deuxième réponse
est une réponse plus financière et je
vais me situer dans le prolongement de
ce qu'a dit Philippe on nen avait pas
parlé mais je je je souscris ement à ce
que Philippe a dit notamment sur la
question du Nasdaq je suis absolument
convaincu qu'il nous manque un marché
financier en Europe euronex c'est très
bien mais c'est pas la même cult enfin
un marché financier de l'innovation
c'est quelque chose qui est très
particulier avec une culture
particulière avec des analystes
particuliers avec
euronex n'a pas ça et je pense en plus
que ce sera un formidable projet pour
pour alors on va pas le faire à 27 bien
évidemment parce que parce que ce serait
trop compliqué et il faut le faire
relativement vite mais je pense que
essayer de se mettre d'accord avec
quelques pays pour essayer d'organiser
un Nasdaq européen ce serait vraiment
quelque chose qui serait un un nouveau
projet donc une idée assez assez
grandiose et en plus on en a absolument
besoin le problème de de l'économie
européenne notamment en matière
d'innovation Philippe évoqua le cas
deintelligence artificielle générative
c'est pas un problème d'amorçage il y a
énormément de start-up en Europe il y en
a plein c'est même pas un problème de
recherche et développement parce qu'il y
a de la recherche et développement en
Europe c'est le passage de la recherche
et développement au moment où une
entreprise vraiment va pouvoir
industrialiser sa sa production et là on
a besoin d'avoir un marché qui comprend
ça qui comprend les enjeux de
l'innovation qui valorise les enjeux de
l'innovation qui est quand même
suffisamment profond et liquide pour
apporter des montants qui sont
conséquents et ça ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui en Europe et et c'est une
perte sèche pour notre économie parce
que ça signifie que un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui arrivent quasement à
maturité vont se faire côter au Nasdaq
et donc Infiné vont finir quand même par
pencher plutôt du côté
américain juste si je peux me permettre
de juste rajouter j'ai demandé au
président
l'autorisation je je crois par rapport à
votre question monsieur le sénateur
qu'on ne peut pas dans le temps qui
vient dire on va continuer à financer
l'ancien modèle et le nouveau parce que
ça veut dire vous serez pas assez sur le
nouveau si je reprends mon exemple de
tout à l'heure la France est devenue la
première puissance automobile au début
du 20e siècle parce qu'on a dit non non
on va pas financer les maréchau Ferran
les aras et l'automobile le choix
c'était un choix de l'épargnant français
c'estàdire les gens on dit moi j'y crois
dans ce truccl j'y vais euh il y avait à
peu près 200 ou 250 firmes automobiles
avant la Première Guerre mondiale elles
ont toutes disparu c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a plein de gens qui ont perdu évidemment
parce que ils avaient raison mais ils se
sont trompés sur la cible mais je pense
qu'effectivement nous sommes à un moment
où le problème de l'Europe c'est de
vouloir continuer à faire le
fonctionnement c'est pour ça ma réserve
tout à l'heure sur la question
industrielle on peut pas être en même
temps oui ça devient politique ce que je
dis là donc simultanément simultanément
en train de financer le Nouveau Monde et
l'ancien monde on est d'accord que
financer l'ancien monde ça plaît aux
citoyens qui comme je disais par par
nature comme tout humain préfère quand
même le monde qui connaît nous sommes à
un moment de changement tel que je pense
qu'il faut absolument que nous dirigions
prioritairement tous nos capacités
financières l'Europe a d'énormes
capacité financière nous avons une
épargne absolument monstrueuse par
rapport aux Américains mais nous avons
la possibilité aussi de développer
quelque chose que nous ne faisons pas
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire depuis 250 ans que parmi les
plus grandes entreprises mondiales qui
Val le plus cher quand je dis qu' Val le
plus cher c'estàdire que Google peut
acheter s'ils veulent sans s'endetter
LVMH il ny pense pas une seconde on est
d'accord mais elle va macheter la plus
grosse capitalisation européenne c'est
la première fois dans l'histoire que
l'Europe n'est pas dans les grandes
entreprises c'est pas normal parce que
nous concentrons notre épargne nous
concentrons nos financements sur les
entreprises du passé comme la Chine
beaucoup trop comme la Chine et pas
assez sur celle du
futur merci Monsieur deertine on va on
va grouper les questions pour les les
deux missions qui maintenant sont
lancées puisque sur mission euh entre
finance entreprise et climat on a un
seul rapporteur qui est présent donc
Simon usénade pour la mission entreprise
et climat pour la mission entreprise et
climat et on a Pauline Martin et et et
Pierre Antoine levvi qui sont présents
pour le les les questions sur la mission
du financement de l'entreprise de demain
donc on va commencer par par ça merci
monsieur le Président merci pour vos
interventions absolument passionnantes
moi je voulais euh vous interroger parce
que j'ai j'ai bien entendu vos propos
sur le rôle des petites entreprises en
tant que catalyseur de de l'innovation
et donc au-delà même de la préfiguration
du du Nouveau Monde h comment eu ça
rejoint la la question du
financement comment voyez-vous les les
moyens à la fois juridiques et et
financiers d'aider ces petites
entreprises parce que j'ai eu une
expérience où j'ai accompagné une
branche en l'occurrence numérique
ingénierie conseil sur l'expérimentation
de label sectoriel RSE et où on voyait
bien comment dire plus de 80 % des
entreprises moins de 10 salariés il y
avait une appétence évidemment des
dirigeants d'entreprise qui eux-mêmes se
retrouvent prescripteurs pour leurs
clients sur ces sujets de de
transformation plutôt que de transition
la réalité c'est que à un moment donné
ces petites entreprises rencontraient
des difficultés
majeur pour mettre en œuvre ces ces
transformations au sein de leur
organisation et évidemment pour se
retrouver plus efficacement
prescriptrice auprès de leurs clients
donc comment quels outils vous imaginez
pour que justement cet écosystème là
vous preniez l'exemple de l'automobile
au début du 20e siècle se se mettre en
ligne pour nous permettre justement de
favoriser l'émergence de de ce nouveau
monde dans lequel nous voyons des
opportunités y compris pour les les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui ont
peut-être un peu trop le regard tourné
dans le
rétroviseur
pour financement de l'entreprise de
demain mes chers
collègues oui merci monsieur le
Président merci messieurs j'ai eu
l'occasion d'entendre Nicolas bouou sur
d'autres sujets c'est toujours
intéressant et j'ai été captivé
également par les propos de Philippe de
serertine qui nous a donné finalement
une leçon de ce qui peut nous attendre
demain et c'est à quoi nous devons nous
préparer nous les politiques alors
messieur moi j'ai une question à vous
poser concernant le la RD on a toujours
dit que la France je crois que vous
l'aviez dit é une terre propice à la red
mais pas au financement du risque
autrement dit les grandes entreprises y
placent le centre de recherche mais les
start-up innovantes préfèrent partir aux
États-Unis pour trouver des
investisseurs et financer leur
croissance alors qu'est-ce qui nous
manque aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas est-ce que vous pensez
que des propositions de on pourrait
intervenir pour permettre d'inverser
cette tendance et nous permettre
effectivement de revenir aujourd'hui à
des à cette légitimité que la France
avait en début du siècle et et
d'accueillir finalement des start-ups
avant qu'elle parte aux États-Unis
bien sûr question alors rapidement bon
je je je me joins au au remerciement de
de mon collègue on va aller plus vite
comme ça juste il semblerait quand même
qu'en France nos entreprises a un
certain nombre d'handicap et en
particulier la faiblesse de leurs fonds
propres à votre avis à quoi c'est dû
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas et
surtout à quoi c'est dû et et est-ce que
ça freine réellement leur leur capacité
d'investissement juste pour approfondir
juste les les propos de Pierre-Antoine
Lévi je fais également partie du groupe
d'étude d'amitié France États-Unis et on
avait fait intervenir un certain nombre
de juristes et chefs d'entreprise qui
nous disaient que
effectivement les Américains quand ils
viennent en France c'est pour faire du
Red et ils vont faire leur développement
leur production de richesse et et et le
reste aux États-Unis et que des français
quand ils vont s'installer aux
États-Unis un peu le rêve américain ils
font l'installation le développement la
production de richesse et ils installe
la famille aux
États-Unis alors je va je vais essayer
d'être synthétique parce que ce sont des
des sujets en soi en
réalité sur la la question du du
financement de l'innovation bon j'ai
j'ai j'ai évoqué la question d'un
nasdaac Européen j'y reviens pas on a un
sujet Philipp pas commencé à en parler
en prenant l'exemple du du début du 20e
siècle mais on a un sujet d'orientation
de l'éparne des Français parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait très longtemps qu'on
dit et c'est avéré par les études que
les entreprises françaises ont moins de
fonds propres que nos que nos principaux
concurrents c'est très important dans
une période comme celle-ci où les
investissements qui sont à consentir par
les entreprises sont des investissements
qui sont risqués donc qui sont plus
adaptés à un financement par fond propre
qu'àun financement bancaire et donc on
un sujet majeur d'orientation de de
l'épargne qui en France est une épargne
qui est non risquée je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur le fait que certes
comme la diff CER on a beaucoup
d'épargne en Europe et en France mais
cette épargne est très largement absorbé
par nos déficits publics euh et donc il
faut bien avoir ça en tête qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire si on est concret ça veut
dire que l'assurance vie est un
placement qui absorbe énormément
d'épargne parce que il faut bien aller
financer nos no nos déf icite public
hein donc si on veut que cette épargne
alors je sais que c'est c'est compliqué
à entendre parce que ça va pas se faire
en 3 jours mais si on veut que l'épargne
des Français aille plus vers les
entreprises tout simplement ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut réduire les besoins de
financement de l'État pour laisser
davantage de place à cette à cette
épargne après bah il faut alors on a
commencé à le faire hein on a déjà des
des des produits bancaires qui sont
censés s'investir dans dans les
entreprises avec des avantages fiscaux
bon ça fonctionne pas trop mal mais on
voit qu'on est encore en de ça de ce
qu'il faut faire donc là on a un sujet
d'ingénierie financière je dirais je
pense qu'on n'est pas allé encore tout
au bout de ce qu'on de ce qu'on doit
faire sur la question de la recherche et
et développement
oui là encore je souscris complètement à
ce qui a été été dit la recherche et
développement en France alors on en
alors là je vais reprendre la typologie
qui a été faite par par Philippe en fait
on en fait beaucoup et on innove
beaucoup en France dans des secteurs pas
très innovant et en fait ce qui nous
manque c'est de l'innovation dans la
robotique dans l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
dans dans le qu dans l'informatique
quantique là très clairement on n'est
pas du tout là où on devrait être et
c'est un sujet qui d'ailleurs est un
sujet européen euh je pense que là
encore il faut qu'on développe beaucoup
la pédagogie sur ces questions sur ces
questions d'innovation il faut qu'on
explique que c'est pas simplement une
question technique et économique mais
c'est aussi une question de souveraineté
c'est aussi une question géopolitique
les Américains ont parfaitement compris
ça le président évoquit les les
États-Unis les Américains ont
parfaitement compris que la l'influence
le poids géopolitique les attributs
peut-être plus d'une hyperpuissance mais
d'une superpuissance trouvent largement
leur racine dans la maîtrise de la
science et dans la maîtrise de de
l'innovation ça c'est quelque
chose qu'en Europe à mon sens on n pas
du tout compris on n' pas encore fait ce
ce lien et pourtant quand vous en parlez
même avec les diplomates du Kenor il
vous expliqueent parfaitement que cette
perte de de de maîtrise relative de la
science et de la technologie aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui pèse c'est
parfois très concret hein la question
des cyber cyberattaques par exemple donc
donc je suis entièrement d'accord avec
vous je pense qu'il faut qu'on revoit un
certain nombre de programmes publics je
vais être très précis France 2030 par
exemple
c'est bien c'est bien sur le papier
alors déjà je pense qu'il faut le
transformer en France 2050 rapidement
mais avec France 2030 on est retombé
dans un défaut qui là encore fait partie
des charmes de notre pays mais qui est
malgré tout un défaut c'est le fait que
les les les programmes sont beaucoup
trop dispersés moi j'ai découvert avec
un certain effarmement que vous aviez
des montants enfin des fonds France 2030
qui allent distribuer 20 ou 30000 € à
des programmes artisanaux alors attendez
je pense que c'est très bien de soutenir
l'artisanat mais je pense que 20000 € ça
n'a aucun sens et le mettre dans France
2030 ça n'a aucun sens j'aime bien que
les choses soient un peu structuré
intellectuellement et
institutionnellement vous voyez donc je
pense que France 2030 ça doit être des
montants importants ça peut pas être des
dizaines de milliers je dir même ça peut
même pas être des centaines de milliers
d'euros je pense qu'il faut compter en
millions et donc ça doit être des
montants
important pour des projets qui sont des
projets très innovants et qui sont déjà
des projets un peu matures c'est pas
l'amorçage l'amorçage en France ça va
très bien donc faut oubl
le la startup nation on y est déjà et le
risque c'est qu'on y reste c'est ça le
risque de la France c'est que la France
reste une une startup nation donc je
pense qu'il faut encore qu'on remette de
l'ordre dans nos programmes de soutien
public qui sont pas mal sur le papier
mais qui retombent très rapidement dans
nos travers
oui donc euh je reprends je rebondis sur
ce que dit Nicolas oui le problème c'est
pas start c'est up quoi c'est qu'on est
surtout start c'est pas assez up et donc
là on est un peu comme un film de John
Ford c'està dire l'image du début va
être la même que celle de la fin là ce
que vous évoquez monsieur le sénateur
sur la problématique de la PME en fait
elle est double c'est un pour que on
aille vite il faut de l'argent donc il
faut lever des fonds et il faut beaucoup
plus de fonds et beaucoup plus vite
parce que on est dans l'urgence mais de
faut qu'on aille vite à tout point de
vue et là effectivement on retrouve ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire
la France est le pays en Europe aussi
dans lequel on est trop lent dans je
dirais tous les procédures
d'accompagnement que vous avez évoqué et
cetera tous les éléments qui vont faire
que ça prend trop de temps et donc là je
crois que la grande question et là ça
veut dire effectivement du point de vue
de l'État on peut y revenir aussi en
disant c'est quoi le rôle de l'État dans
une période de super innovation en
France et malheureusement on a quand
même cette tendance à dire mais l'État
va être présent va être partout où il
faut vous inquiétez pas on va mettre
l'argent non non arrêtons c'est pas du
tout le rôle de l'État et d'ailleurs
l'État ne saura pas il aura pas les
moyens et en plus ce sera compliqué d'un
point de vue politique dans les périodes
d'innovation ça veut dire vous allez
perdre l'argent du du contribuable donc
en général c'est moyennement apprécié au
moment des élections donc l'État doit
faciliter doit tout mettre pour doit
tout mettre en œuvre pour que cette
innovation tousasimud puisse fonctionner
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
quand on évoquait tout à l'heure
l'accélération des procédures publiques
c'est fondamental et on doit mettre tous
les moyens pour le cût de l'État
là-dedans ça veut dire effectivement
rentrer dans la robotisation passage
d'ailleurs on est extrêmement bas dans
le classement de la robotisation
mondiale ça on doit le savoir hein c'est
quelque chose où on n absolument pas au
niveau de la puissance économique
française et donc la question du robot
la question de tous les outils de
technologie pour accélérer les choses
mise au service de l'État dans cette
idée avec un seul tableau de bord un un
seul indicateur combien de temps quelle
vitesse je le disais tout à l'heure pour
la justice c'est à tous ces niveaux-là
qu'on a cette problématique parce que ce
que vous évoquez monsieur le sénateur
c'est la possibilité la perspective
ensuite de basculer sur la capacité de
lever des fonds et là effectivement on
on recoupe avec la question que vous
aviez oui bien sûr la France est un pays
shooté à la dette on parle de la dette
publique la dette privée est beaucoup
trop élevé et quand on dit la dette
privée c'est la dette des ménages et la
dette des entreprises parce que quand on
dit qu'il y a pas fond propre c'est
clair ça veut dire qu'on se finance par
la dette donc ça veut dire que on est la
dette à tous les étages alors pourquoi
pourquoi on va dire vous allez me dire
mais pourquoi on utilise la dette parce
que un on avait des taux très faibles de
parce que c'est notre culture mais TR
parce qu'on n pas compris à quoi ça sert
un fond propre un fond propre ça sert à
quoi ça sert à perdre de l'argent
c'estàdire le problème quand vous avez
de la dette c'est que si vous pouvez pas
rembourser 1 € de votre dette vous êtes
en défaut si vous avez une perte ça veut
dire qu'effectivement votre bilan est se
cont TRX donc vous avez plus les moyens
de rembourser votre dette vous êtes en
défaut résultat ça vous empêche d'aller
sur le risque sur la red sur les
éléments dans lesquels par défi sinon
vous allez perdre à quoi ça sert les
fonds propres ça sert que quand vous
avez du résultat négatif c'est le
propriétaire qui prend la perte et
l'entreprise est continue c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça évidemment qu'il faut
lui expliquer qu'à un moment donné il
peut gagner un petit peu et donc c'est
là aussi une réflexion publique en
disant si vous voulez renforcer les
fonds propres il faut évidemment qu'on
arrête de stigmatiser les dividendes le
dividende c'est fait pourquoi c'est fait
pour dire à l'actionnaire quand de temps
en temps tu gagnes tu vas en avoir un
peu de profit parce que si vous lui
dites tu es là en fait pour perdre
d'ailleurs tu vas perdre de plus en plus
parce qu'on rentre dans une rupture
technologique où de plus en plus il va y
avoir des pertes donc ça tu vas perdre
beaucoup mais en revanche quand tu vas
gagner alors là on est désolé on va être
obligé de te taxer tu comprends parce
que tu vas gagner de façon insensée bah
là ça marchera pas ça c'est clair que
quand on est dans la logique comment on
va renforcer les comment on va attirer
l'épargne on a dit l'épargne elle est
bloquer un dans la dette publique qui va
faire que l'État dit ah mais moi j'ai
les moyens d'investir c'est le plan en
France 2030 c'est la banque publique
d'investissement on vous dit mon compte
en milliards non non non non non non le
défi c'est en milliers de milliards on n
est pas là on n'est pas à l'échelle je
le répète les grandes entreprises du
monde aujourd'hui elles ont une seule
entreprise du monde à une valeur plus
forte que le PIB de la 7e 8e puissance
mondiale qui est la France aujourd'hui
on doit avoir conscience de ça on n'est
plus à la bonne échelle et donc la bonne
échelle c'est effectivement notre trép
qui est bloqué un dans le financement de
l'État mais aussi deux d'ailleurs dans
l'immobilier français au passage hein
donc effectivement bah la France qui
effectivement a osé investir dans
l'innovation quand ça a été je dirais sa
grande période et on do évidemment
regardez hein après la défaite de 70 au
moment de la guerre de 14 effectivement
les les Français disaient il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose parce que sinon on
est en train de décliner hein l'idée du
déclin de la France était très présent
dans les années 1900 et d'ailleurs aussi
dans les années 1900 et là les Français
ont réagi en disant ok je mets de
l'argent c'est bien c'est le boulot des
vieux ça l'épargne c'est au vieux on a
dit c'est un pays vieillissant
formidable on a un levier extraordinaire
il faut l'utiliser il faut l'utiliser
pour le mettre en fond propre alors je
suis d'accord avec toi Nicolas quand tu
disais tout à l'heure que on est bon sur
l'amorçage je regarde quand même la
traduction de venture capital qui est
fondamentale dans le Nasdaq aux
États-Unis ventur en France on traduit
ça capital risque venture ça veut dire
aventure le capital d'aventure c'est pas
tout à fait la même gueule que le
capital risque parce que risque vous
êtes en train de dire vous allez perdre
c'est clair c'est pour ça que vous êtes
là mais vous êtes aussi pour aussi
prendre l'aventure l'aventure économique
donc je crois que là il y a cette
question de mentalité cette question de
motivation il est clair que la question
fiscale est très importante c'est-à-dire
vous allez motiver les gens quand même à
un moment donné en disant sur la
problématique fiscale si vraiment dieu
sais si je m'intéresse au problème de
l'équilibre des finances publiques
regardons sur les questions des
transmissions ça peut être une façon
aussi on a vu l'assurance vie
aujourd'hui ça rapporte rien enfin
pardon là je sais que son est diffusé et
je vais avoir tous les surureurv qui
vont me tomber dessus mais enfin ça
rapporte moins avec l'inflation
néanmoins l'élément moteur c'est la
manière dont on va pouvoir transmettre
son patrimoine ce serait pas idiot qu'on
pense à la même chose sur la façon dont
on veut renforcer les fonds propres dont
on veut renforcer la capacité des
entreprises à perdre de l'argent en
prenant du risque je le répète c'est
comme ça qu'il faut parler des fonds
propres hein donc voilà peut-être très
vite merci beaucoup messieurs euh merci
chers collègues et merci pour cette
j'allais presque dire bouffée d'oxygène
que vous nous avez apporté ce matin de
d'un très très haut niveau et et et des
propos de très haute qualité vraiment on
est très heureux de vous avoir accueilli
ce matin euh je pense qu'on va être dans
l'obligation de de de d'en arrêter là
parce que merci aussi à Monsieur
desertine d'avoir pris un peu sur le
temps qui vous éta imparti parce que
vous avez pris sur quelque chose qui
vous était prévu pour venir mais vous
deviez quand même partir assez
rapidement pour aller rejoindre cet
événement so à la défense
voilà donc vraiment merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur
Bouzou de tous ces éclaircissements et
de la encore une fois de la qualité des
propos que vous avez tenu ce matin je
vous rappelle juste mes chers collègues
qu' y aura pas de de réunion la semaine
prochaine puisque nous sommes en
déplacement dans Les pérines Orientales
merci à tous et je vous souhaite une
excellente
journée